THE JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE IN THE
SENATE ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
COMMITTEE ON THE SUBJECT OF
EVALUATING CALIFORNIA'S RECALL
PROCESS. BEFORE WE GET INTO THE
SUBSTANCE OF THIS HEARING A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENTS TO
MAKE. DO THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WE CONTINUE TO OPERATE
WITH MODIFIED COMMITTEE
PROCEDURES. ANY INDIVIDUAL IS
PRESENT IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
MUST WEAR A MASK OVER THEIR
MOUTH AND NOSE AT ALL TIMES. WE
ALSO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO TESTIFY IN THE
COMMITTEE. INCLUDING ALLOWING
TESTIMONY AT A REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION ON THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL. AND ALLOWING
TESTIMONY BY PHONE. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE GOAL OF TODAY'S
HEARING. AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC
WITHIN OUR TOWN LIMITS IN TERMS
OF HEARING THE PUBLIC. WILL NOT
TOLERATE CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS.
WHAT DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
TODAY'S HEARING. PLEASE BE AWARE
THAT VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES
MAY SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVAL OR
OTHER ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS. WE
HAVE TWO SPEAKERS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. AFTER THE COMMITTEE
HEARS FROM THESE EXPERT
WITNESSES THERE WILL BE TIME FOR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE COMMITTEE. IS
ABLE TO COMPLETE OUR BUSINESS IN
THE A LOT OF TIME TO HEAR FROM
AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY WILL BE LIMITED
AS FOLLOWS. WE'LL SET ASIDE ONE
HOUR FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
STARTING WITH MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC CORE HERE IN THE WRONG.
EACH PERSON WILL HAVE ONE MINUTE
TO MAKE THEIR REMARKS. MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ARE ALSO
ENCOURAGED TO SUBMIT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE COMMITTEES.
THIS WRITTEN TESTIMONY WILL
BECOME PART OF THE OFFICIAL
RECORD OF THE HEARING. FOR THOSE
WHO ARE WATCHING THIS HEARING
REMOTELY. AND WISH TO CALL IN TO
SPEAK DURING THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY PORTION OF THE HEARING
THE CALL IN NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR
TWO OH TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV OR
COMPUTER COMPUTER SCREEN. I'LL
REPEAT THIS CALL INFORMATION
ONCE WE GET TO THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY PORTION OF TODAY'S
HEARING. IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
TWENTY NINETY FOUR. AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP YOU
. THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US
AS WE IMPLEMENT THESE METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WITH ALL OF THE
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENTS OUT
OF THE WAY LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
TOPIC. OF TODAY'S HEARING.
TODAY'S COMMITTEE TODAY THE
COMMITTEES THIRD JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
CALIFORNIA RECALL PROCESS. IT'S
ALSO THE FIRST SUCH HEARING
SINCE I WAS NAMED CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS COMMITTEE.
BACK IN DECEMBER. HOWEVER I WAS
PLEASED TO PARTICIPATE IN PRIOR
HEARINGS FOR BEING AN OFFICIAL
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE. AND AS
THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO BUILD
UPON THE WORK. THAT THE
COMMITTEES. I PLAN ON DOING. AND
HAVE BEEN UPLIFTED IN THESE
FIRST TWO HEARINGS I SPECIALLY
WANT TO GIVE. IT KNOWLEDGE MEANT
. TO MY COLLEAGUE IN THE SENATE
CHAIR GLAZER FOR ALL OF HIS
EFFORTS. AND STEWARDING THIS
JOINT PROCESS. YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN PARTNERSHIP IS PART OF WHY
WE'VE GOTTEN THIS FAR AND I
THINK IT'S- GOING TO BE
ESSENTIAL FOR US TO CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD. THE RECALLS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIRECT DEMOCRACY PROCESS. IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT THAT WE REGULARLY
EVALUATE THAT PROCESS TO ENSURE
THAT ITS RULES AND FRAMEWORK
MEET THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA AND
WORK AS THEY WERE ORIGINALLY
DESIGNED. LAST SEPTEMBER'S
GUBERNATORIAL RECALL ELECTION.
THE SECOND OF SENATE ELECTIONS
IN THE LAST EIGHTEEN YEARS
PROVIDE US WITH THE PERFECT
OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE HOW THAT
PROCESS CAN BE IMPROVED. AND
WHILE THE INTENDED RECALL THE
GOVERNOR HAS RECEIVED THE
GREATEST AMOUNT OF TENSION IN
THE PRESS. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT IS CLEAR FROM THE FIRST TWO
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS THAT
THERE ARE LESSONS WE CAN LEARN.
FROM CHANGES IN THE USE OF THE
RECALL PROCESS. AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. WE CAN'T ALLOW THE
RECALL PROCESS TO BECOME A TOOL
USED TO ATTEMPT TO SUBVERT THE
ELECTORAL WILL OF THE PEOPLE. AT
THE SAME TIME. IT'S IMPORTANT WE
MAIN A MAIN MAINTAIN A
MEANINGFUL ABILITY. FOR THE
ELECTORS TO REMOVE A PERSON FROM
OFFICE BEFORE THE END OF THEIR
TERM. SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR JOINT EFFORTS TO
EVALUATE THE SHORTCOMINGS OF OUR
CURRENT RECALL SYSTEM. AND TO
ENSURE THAT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. HAVE A SYSTEM THAT
WORKS FOR THEM. I'M EXCITED TO
HEAR FROM OUR EXPERT WITNESSES
TODAY WILL GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING NOT ONLY OF THE
CHALLENGES IN OUR CURRENT RECALL
PROCESS. IT ALSO ABOUT HOW
CALIFORNIANS FEEL ABOUT THAT
PROCESS BASED ON THE SURVEY DATA
FROM PP I SEE. SO THANK YOU IN
ADVANCE FOR THE WITNESSES WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARINGS. AND TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE TWO COMMITTEES. THAT ARE
TAKING TIME OUT OF THEIR
SCHEDULES TO BE PRESENT HERE
TODAY. I'M INCREDIBLY OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT THE WORK THAT WE CAN DO
TOGETHER. AND WITH THAT I'LL
TURN THINGS OVER TO CHECK GLAZER
FOR HIS OPENING REMARKS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU AT YOUR BRYANT-
AND THANK YOU FOR SEAMLESSLY
PICKING UP THE LEADERSHIP OF
THIS COMMITTEE FROM HER BERMAN
I'VE REALLY ENJOYED GETTING TO
KNOW YOU AND TO- WORK WITH YOU.
AND I THINK THIS PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN OUR HOUSES IS A IS A
REALLY EXCELLENT EXAMPLE FOR HOW
WE- CAN COME TOGETHER AND WORK
TOGETHER TALK THROUGH A LOT OF
THESE DIFFICULT ISSUES. IN A
CONSTRUCTIVE POSITIVE WAY AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
CONTINUING THAT THAT
PARTNERSHIP. AS YOU MENTIONED AT
OUR PRIOR HEARINGS WE DID HEAR
FROM. DISTINGUISHED ELECTED
LEADERS AND EXPERTS FROM ACROSS
THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM. ON THE
NEED FOR CHANGING THE RECALL
PROCESS AND DIFFERENT WAYS FOR
DOING THIS. SECRETARY OF STATE
WEBER WAS OUR FIRST SPEAKER AT
OUR FIRST HEARING IN OCTOBER.
AND WE APPRECIATED HEARING HER.
EXPERTISE AND HER WISDOM AS SHE
TALKED ABOUT THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT YOU KNOW THE SECOND
pGUBERNATORIAL CALL AND STATE
HISTORY. AND SHE DID MENTION TO
US THAT SHE WAS CONDUCTED OUR
OWN REVIEW AND I THINK IT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE THAT WE HEAR FROM
HER TODAY. SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO
BENEFIT FROM HER WISDOM AND
INSIGHT. I'M ALSO VERY PLEASED
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING FROM
THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE CEO
DR MARK BALL THE SORRY- HE'S
CONDUCTED TWO POLLS- THAT
INCLUDED QUESTIONS ON THIS
RECALL PROCESS. AND I'M VERY.
PLEASE THAT HE HAS CONTINUED
THAT RESEARCH IS GOING TO SHARE
WITH US TODAY FRESH INFORMATION-
ON THE RECALL PROCESS FROM A
THIRD POLL THAT HE HAS DONE. AS
I HAVE SAID FROM THE ONSET IN
THIS PROCESS THAT THE RECALL IS
AN IMPORTANT TOOL OF THE
ELECTORATE. TO HOLD OFFICIALS
ACCOUNTABLE ONE THAT I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. HOWEVER AS WE HAVE
HEARD FROM MANY WITNESSES-
THERE'S SOME ISSUES THERE'S SOME
CONCERNS THERE SOME DEMOCRATIC
FLIES. ABOUT HOW THE PROCESS IS
CONDUCTED IN CALIFORNIA. AND
IT'S A PART OF OUR PROCESS TODAY
AND PREVIOUSLY TO TRY TO EXAMINE
THAT DEEPLY AND POTENTIALLY PUT
FORWARD ALTERNATIVES FOR THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA TO
CONSIDER. SO WITH THAT I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATIONS
TODAY TURN MATTER BACK TO CHIP
REID. THANK YOU TRIGGERING FOR
AS WAS MENTIONED SECRETARY
WEBER. ATTENDED THE FIRST OF
THESE INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS AND
I THINK IT'S ONLY FITTING. THAT
WE BRING HER BACK FOR THE FINAL
HEARING. I TO SHARE NEW
PERSPECTIVES FROM HER OFFICE'S
REVIEW. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
NOT FAMILIAR WITH DOCTOR WEBER I
THINK WE ALL ARE BUT- SHE SERVED
IN THE LEGISLATURE FROM TWENTY
TWELVE UNTIL HER APPOINTMENT AS
SECRETARY OF STATE. IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DURING THE
TIME OF THE LEGISLATURE DR WEBER
SERVED AS A CHAIR. FOR THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE THIS.
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS IN RESISTING
COMMITTEE AND THE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY AS
WELL AS A MEMBER OF THE
EDUCATION ALEXION'S.
REDISTRICTING HIGHER EDUCATION
AND BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEES. ALSO ON THE FIRST
DAY OF BLACK HISTORY MONTH I
pRECOGNIZE. DR WEBER'S POSITION
AS THE FIRST BLACK WOMAN TO HOLD
THE CONSTITUTIONAL POSITION SHE
HOLDS TODAY- WE'RE HONORED. I
SEE AN ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE SOME OPENING
COMMENTS SO WILL MAKE SPACE FOR
THAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND JUST BRIEFLY- I'VE BEEN
THROUGH. A WHOLE SERIES OF THESE
HEARINGS THUS FAR. AND AS WE
COMMENCE TODAY I'VE BEEN
INCREASINGLY OF A MIND THAT
THERE IS NO NEED TO CHANGE. THE
RECALL PROCESS CERTAINLY NO
SIGNIFICANTLY. AND THAT'S BECOME
MORE OF A HARDENED POSITION WITH
ME THE MORE WE'VE BEEN THROUGH
THE SHARING. FURTHER THE SUMMONS
WITNESSES WHO SPEAK AT LENGTH.
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY WHO HAVE
BEEN. OPPOSED TO CHANGING THE
RECALL OR MAINTAINING IF YOU OF
THE STATUS QUO WE'VE HAD MOST
ALL WITNESSES WERE IN SOME
MANNER OR ANOTHER CRITICAL. AND
FURTHER AND THIS IS JUST AN
INDICTMENT THE WHOLE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD
USED TO BE RELEVANT HERE. BUT
OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS FOR A LOT
OF REASONS- BEING BLAMED ON A
CULL WOULD FOR ONE. PUBLIC
COMMENT IS PRETTY WELL MEETINGS
. PEOPLE CALL IN. AND WE WANT AS
WELL JUST HAVE THE MODERATOR
TAKE A POLL FIVE FOUR FOUR
AGAINST. THIS IS NOT WHERE YOU
GET ONE MINUTE. OR IN OUR OWN
HEARINGS LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS
THEY GET TO SAY I'M JOE- FOR-
JANE- AGAINST. LAYS DOWN THAT IS
NOT PUBLIC INPUT AND I WISH THE
PUBLIC. WITH THAT LETTER OUTRAGE
BEACH SHEEN ABOUT HOW THERE ARE
HAVING LESS OPPORTUNITY. SO WILL
PROCEED AND WE'LL HAVE ANOTHER
HEARING TODAY AND I THANK YOU OF
DOLLARS EACH YEAR. THANK YOU IN
WITH THAT WILL TURN IT OVER TO
OUR SECRETARY OF STATE DOCTOR
WEB. THANK YOU VICE YOU'RE
CERTAIN THANK YOU FOR. ALLOWING
ME TO. A COUPLE OF WORDS ABOUT
THE PROCESS I SHARE SOME OF THE
SENTIMENTS THAT ARE GOOD
SENATOR- NIELSEN ALSO- HAS
ECHOED- BUT I I'D LIKE TO SEE
SOME BALLOTS SOME PEOPLE THAT DO
OF IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION. BECAUSE
EVERYTHING WE'VE HEARD AND I
GREATLY RESPECT THE- A INTELLECT
IN THE POLITICIAN YEAH- INPUT.
BUT A LOT OF TIMES OTHER PEOPLE
THAT ARE SUBJECTED TO THE RECALL
PROCESS AND DON'T REALLY WANT
IT- I WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE OF
A STATE WITH HEARING FROM PEOPLE
THAT- THAT. HAVE ISSUES WITH
CHANGING THE PROCESS BECAUSE
CHANGING THE PROCESS- MEANS
DENYING ACCESS TO OUR ELECTORAL
PROCESS- WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
I THOUGHT WE HAVE BEEN TRYING
DESPERATELY TO. ALLOW MORE
ACCESS NOT LESS- ALSO YOU'D
MENTIONED IT WAS WE HAD TO-
RECALLS OF THE GOVERNOR THE PAST
EIGHTEEN YEARS WELL WE ALSO ONLY
HAD TO IN THE PAST HUNDRED TEN
YEARS. SO TRYING TO RECALL THE
GOVERNOR THAT HAS ACTUALLY GONE
TO A BALLOT- SO- I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING SOME MORE COMMENTS-
THIS MORNING- BUT I REALLY WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR COMMENTS FROM
PEOPLE WHO HAVE CONCERNS WITH
CHANGING THE PROCESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE THOSE
OPENING REMARKS AND I THINK
IT'S- IT'S WONDERFUL THAT WE
HAVE P. P. I SEE HERE TODAY TO
SHOW PULLED FROM THE PEOPLE
DIRECTLY. AND BEFORE WE GET TO
THAT. MADAM SECRETARY DR WEBER
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE WITH YOU AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE EARLIER NOT ONLY BY
YOU- CHAIR BRYANT AND ALSO-
SHARE GLAZER AND YOUR EFFORTS TO
WORK TOGETHER TO- AS IN A FIVE
PART IN A AND I'M- IN A ACROSS
HOUSE MANNER SO THAT WE GET OUR
SENATE AND OUR ASSEMBLY
TOGETHER. ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE- I READ WITH YOU AT THE
BEGINNING OF YOUR OF YOUR-
SESSIONS AND EXPRESSED TO YOU AT
THAT TIME SOME CONCERNS I HAD
BUT I SAID AT THE SAME TIME. BUT
I DIDN'T WANT THIS JUST TO BE
THE SHIRLEY WEBER SHOW THAT THAT
THIS IS NOT JUST WHEN SHE THINKS
ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN AND
SO I WANTED TO CONSULT WITH
OTHERS AROUND THE STATE TO FIND
OUT OF THEIR THINKING AND- WE
DID A BI PARTISAN KIND OF. OF
ACTIVITY AND SO WHAT I DID
INSTEAD OF ME BASICALLY SERVING
BECAUSE I KNEW THAT YEAH I WOULD
BE A GREAT SURVEYS I ASKED TO
INDIVIDUALS- WHO ARE FROM
DIFFERENT PARTIES. I ASKED THE
FORMER GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN- AND
THE FORMER CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT JUDGE. JUSTICE RIGHT
GEORGE. TO HOLD MY PART OF
CONGRESS. WITH SCHOOL. TO JIM
JONES. THREE COPPER. AND WHAT
THEY MIGHT. CRITICAL AND TIMELY
REFORM IF THEY NEED ALL- THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO HELP REFORM
THE FALL PROCESS. TO ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA'S LONG HELD EMBRACE
OF THE RECALL IS DESIGNED TO
MEET THE NEEDS AND CHANGING
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. AND THAT IT METS
THE NEEDS OF ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE VOTERS
WHERE WE ARE AND THAT WE ALSO.
DON'T FORGET THE MANY WAYS WE
CAN AVOID THE UNNECESSARY TIME
CONSTRAINTS AND COSTS THAT MAKE
CONDUCTING A RECALL DAY IN
ENDEAVOR FULL OF UNNECESSARY
RISKS AND COMPLICATIONS- I WANT
TO SAY THE BEGINNING THAT NO ONE
WHO PARTICIPATED IN THIS PROCESS
OR EAT- HAD ANY RECOMMENDATIONS
TO ELIMINATE THE RECALL PROCESS-
CALIFORNIANS BELIEVE IN- IN
RECALL THEY BELIEVE IN THE-
PUBLIC HAVING AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DO. WHAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN DO
WHICH IS TO. ENGAGE IN AND
REMOVING A PERSON FROM OFFICE
BUT THEY ALSO BELIEVE VERY
STRONGLY THAT- THE UNIQUE THING
OF CALIFORNIANS THAT WE HAVE THE
SAME ABILITY TO DO IN TERMS OF
THE PUBLIC BUT LIKE ANYTHING-
THAT HAS BEEN IN EXISTENCE WAS
LONG AS THIS HAS AND IS THE TIME
TO CHANGE IN TERMS OF THE SIZE
OF THE STATE THE RESOURCES. ALL
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS MAKERS
WANT TO AT LEAST LOOK AT IT AND
TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT WE
THINK ARE SOME ISSUES THAT
CONTINUE TO- MAKE THE RECALL
PROCESS NOT AS EFFECTIVE AS WE'D
LIKE FOR IT TO BE ONE WAY THE
OTHER BUT A TRULY FAIR TO
EVERYONE THAT'S INVOLVED. DO YOU
THINK LAW COMMITTEE ALONG WITH
NAY THING GUARD DALE HELPED ME
AS WE S. STATE AND SERVE JUSTICE
ALONG WITH MY STAFF- OF BROWN
AND CHIEF JUSTICE RON GEORGE-
THEY UTILIZE OUR STAFF AND
INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE THE
NECESSARY- ADMINISTRATIVE
CONTACTS THEM TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS. THE CONTAINER
THAT HOLDS SUCH A COLLECTION OF
INDIVIDUALS WAS THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS HOW JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION THE N. DOUBLE ACP
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE MALL DEATH MALAYO SEIU
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
CALIFORNIA CALLS. HOW MANY CALLS
AND WE ALSO CAN DID THEY ALSO
COULD WITH THE- GUY. GRAY DAVIS.
AND THE FORMER GOVERNOR. ARE
ALSO- THEY MET WITH ALSO TO WITH
A BILL WHERE WEAPONS KIND. RICE
IN THE WHO AND- OF EXT. JOE-
MATTHEWS ALL A GLOBAL FOR THE MY
THERE TO MY- AND PRINT A PETER.
WHO THE DEAN OF PUBLIC POLICY
SCHOOL UP ANYA. SO WE TRIED AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE TO GET A CROSS
SECTION OF INDIVIDUALS. WHO
REPRESENT. VARIOUS PARTIES
VARIOUS IDEOLOGIES TO SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT YOUR TAKE ON THE
RECALL AND RESPOND TO SOME
ISSUES- REFORM ACT AS IS A PART
OF ANY OF THE RECALL PROCESS
SHOULD CONSIDER. THE IMPACT ON
AN OVERALL VOTER ON OVERALL
VOTER PARTICIPATION.
SPECIFICALLY THERE ARE SOME
IDEAS THAT MAY BE HELPFUL IN
TERMS OF THE REFORM THAT'S THERE
BUT WE SHOULD NOT LOSE SIGHT OF
THE FACT THAT WHATEVER WE DO
WILL HAVE A- POSITIVE EFFECT. ON
IT AND EVERY ISSUE YOU HAS ALL
THE ISSUES THAT BECAUSE IT'S A
NOT TO BE AS EFFECTIVE. AND AS A
RESULT WE HAVE TO BALANCE THAT
OUT- BUT IT'S CLEAR UP FROM
ACROSS THE BOARD ITSELF HAD SOME
ISSUES WITH THE RECALL. THAT
THEY FELT COULD BE IMPROVED
COULD BE TWEAKED AND WANT TO
LIVE UP TO THE EXPECTATIONS OF
THE GENERAL PUBLIC- ONE OF THE
MAJOR CONCERNS AS YOU PROBABLY
PROGRAMS THAT PEOPLE DID NOT
THINK THAT WE SHOULD SPLIT THE
ISSUE. BETWEEN THE NO VOTE FOR A
RECALL AND THE END OF THE
SITTING OF THE ISSUE AND A YES
VOTE WILL CONTENDERS. THAT IN
ITSELF PROBABLY CREATED MORE
CONFUSION WITH INDIVIDUALS- THE
MINIMUM CONFUSION AROUND THE
PRIMARY QUESTION OF SUBJECT OF
THE RECALL AND THE
QUALIFICATIONS AND THE MOTORS OF
REPLACEMENT. I HAD A TENDENCY TO
OVERSHADOW WHAT THE RECALL WAS
REALLY ALL ABOUT. AND IT IS
ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT AN
ADDITIONAL ELECTION TAKING PLACE
IF WE DO WORK TO HAVE MORE THAN
ONE. BUT IT SEEMS TO BE PRETTY
GOOD PRETTY CLEAR THAT MOST
FOLKS THOUGHT THAT THE- UP AND-
IT WAS DIFFICULT TO VOTE- FOR
ONE THING AND THEN TO VOTE FOR
THE OTHER THING WOULD SUCH A
HUGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE RUNNING.
AND THEN FEELING AT THE SAME
TIME. BACK TO BECAUSE IT WASN'T
RUNOFF BECAUSE IT WASN'T ANY WAY
TO REALLY HONE. THE REPLY- WE
WERE RUNNING THE RACE OF HAVE
REPLAY. AND VERY LITTLE SUPPORT
FROM THE PUBLIC- THAT IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN PASSED. FIRST TO LESS
VOTE AND BECOME GOVERNOR- TO
REPLACE PERSON WHO GOT MORE
VOTES. IN FAVOR OF THEM- THAN
THAN THE OTHERS AND THAT'S A
REAL FATHER WAS A REAL
POSSIBILITY. WITH REGARDS TO-
THE WAY THIS RECALL IS STILL
STRUCTURE EVERY STATE DOESN'T
STRUCTURE TO RECALL THAT WAY.
AND YET WE HAVE AND CONTINUE TO
DO THAT AND I THINK IT HAS A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT UPON. HOW
FOLKS DECIDE TO VOTE THERE'S
CONCERN ABOUT. THIS REALLY
DOESN'T LIVE UP TO OUR
DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLES IN TERMS
OF THE MAJORITY VOTE AND AS A
RESULT WE END UP WITH. A HUGE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS RUNNING-
WE ALSO WANT TO AND AS A RESULT
OF THAT THERE IS A DISCUSSION
ABOUT- AS YOU PROBABLY HEARD
THAT THE MECHANIC GOVERNOR.
SHOULD ACTUALLY. BE THE
REPLACEMENT CANDIDATE AT LEAST
AT THAT POINT. PEOPLE WHO ARE
VOTING WOULD KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
VOTING FOR. NOT ONLY IN TERMS OF
THE RECALL BUT WHO THEIR BOOK
WHO WOULD TAKE THAT PLACE AND SO
THEREFORE. THEY HAVE A SENSE OF
WHAT'S COMING- THE PAST ELECTION
MADE IT SUCH A DIFFICULT THING
THAT PEOPLE HAD. DIFFERENT
FIGURE OUT WHO WOULD- THEY
VOTING. AT THIS TIME WHEN THE
BUILDING SOME. SO THAT IF THEY
THEY WANTED TO RECALL THE PERSON
THEY MAY NOT LIKE THE CHOI. THAT
WOULD BE A OR FEARFUL THAT THE
CHOICE THAT WERE BEING MADE-
I'LL- ON WHERE THE MOST MONEY
AND ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
WILL LEAVE US WITH A CANDIDATE
OR A SPACE SPLIT- PODOBE
INDIVIDUALS AS WE SELL- ELECTION
. THE CHOICES THAT WERE BEING
GIVEN THAT WE WOULD HAVE HAD
SOMEONE WITH THE PROBLEM. IF THE
30% OF THE TOTAL VOTES AND SO
THAT WAS A CONCERN OF GREAT
CONCERN TO STEER. THE GROUP BUT
ACTUALLY WE- THE LIEUTENANT
OBVIOUSLY CRAZY WITH YOU AND I
GUESS WHAT THE- IN THE MEETINGS
I BIT INTO. SHE KNOW SHE DID
THINK IT WAS A GOOD SYSTEM TO
BASICALLY HAPPY. LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR THERE COULD BE ALL. OF-
WELL. ISSUES OF THEM PUSHING THE
RECALL. SO THEY COULD BECOME GO
OVERNIGHT. I PUT THE REALITY IS
ELECT LIEUTENANT. WHAT THE END
IS. THAT THEY PERSON IS PREPARE
IT WILL BE. TO STEP IN INCOME
THERE IS ANY. OF BACK. IN CASE
THERE IS A- IN CASE THE- REMOVED
THE PERSON FROM. OR IN CASE OF
UP HORRIBLE. OR SOMETHING OF
NATURE I SAW **** IS THE-
GOVERNOR LIKE TO BUY SPREAD.
UNITED ITS PER. TO TAKE ALL-
THERE'S A FEAR. DIFFERENT
PARTIES AND I'LL KINDS OF THINGS
ARE CAN HAPPEN MANY OF THOSE
THINGS. THAT ALSO STOP THAT
MAYBE IF. IN IT SO. THAT THAT IS
WAS GOING TO AT THAT. THAT MODEL
THAT WE GET. ALSO CHANGE WE
ELECT TO. GOVERNORS THAT WE LOOK
LIKE TO NEW TEN GOVERNORS. TO
THE WAY WE SELECTED A VICE
PRESIDENT UNITED STATES. THAT
THE GOVERNOR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
RUN ON THE SAME TICKET. SO THE
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN IF ANYTHING HAPPENS TO
THAT PERSON. WHO WOULD TAKE AND
THEN BASICALLY UPLOADING
FOURTEEN. UP SO THAT WAS ONE OF
THE MAIN THINGS IN FACT MOST
FOLKS FILLED MORE THAN ANYTHING
THAT- THAT. IT LEFT US
VULNERABLE TO END UP WITH THE
WITH THE WITH THE GOVERNOR. WHO-
WHO DID NOT ENJOY THE MAJORITY
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT- WAIT
THEY ALSO COULD. THAT MOST FOLKS
ASK QUESTIONS WHY ARE WE DOING
RECALL ONE OF THE REASONS FOR
THE RECALL. THAT'S ALL THERE IS
DISCUSSION THAT YOU MAY WANT TO
HAVE ABOUT- THE WAY WE IDENTIFY.
WHAT WE THINK IS APPROPRIATE OR
INAPPROPRIATE. SOME ARE SAYING
THAT WE SHOULD USE THE SAME KIND
OF. LANGUAGE THAT WE USE FOR
IMPEACHMENT- THAT THIS IS A FORM
OF IMPEACHMENT BY THE PUBLIC
VERSUS IT AND FORM OF
IMPEACHMENT BY THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT THE STANDARD SHOULD BE TE
SAME AND THEREFORE WE SHOULD
LOOK AT THAT AND BASICALLY
REQUIRE THAT AS A- AS A STANDARD
FOR THE FILING OF. A PAPERS TO
DO A RECALL THAT THEY HAD THE
BIG THIS IS THE PEOPLE SAME
STANDARD OF IMPEACHMENT. AND IS
BASED ON PERFORMANCE AND
BEHAVIOR- THAT IS THE AND THEY
FEEL THAT THE CURRENT LANGUAGE
OF INCAPABLE UNSATISFACTORY IS
TOO LATE. AND AND IS SUBJECT TO
ABUSE. THAT DOUBT THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE THE GREATER STANDARD
SIMILAR LIKE WE HAVE WITH AN
IMPEACHMENT. PROCESS YEAH
CONCERN ABOUT OB. THE CITY
SIGNATURE. AND ENACTED BE BALLOT
WITH OUR- ABOUT PEOPLE. TO HAVE
AN- TO IF WE WAIT IT. TOO HIGH.
WE SAY LIKE SOME STATES YET A
BIT DEPRESSED. OF THE ELECTRIC
WITH ONE FIVE. BUT THAT MAY IT
VERY DIFFICULT IN THIS DAY. TO
ACT FOR THE- TO. ENGAGE IN. BOB
AND SO AND SO OF THE SAID. WAS
THAT SO THAT YOU DON'T END UP AS
WE DO NOW. WE PEOPLE. KIND OF
ANALYZE WHETHER NAY BUSINESS AT
A GOOD IDEA TO DO- A RE. THE OF
THE TERM OUT THAT TOOK PLACE THE
GLOBAL. ELECTION THAT WE SHOULD
ABOUT IT THE STANDARD THIS
WASN'T THE HIGHEST ISSUE THAT
PEOPLE REYES. BUT THINK ABOUT
BASICALLY UTILIZING. OF THE
NUMBERS THAT THAT PRETTY
STANDARD THAT IS BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF REGISTERED VOTERS NOT
NECESSARILY BASED ON THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE. WHO ACTUALLY SHOWED
UP TO VOTE IN AN ELECTION.
BECAUSE EVERYONE HAS AT THE END
OF THE ABILITY TO- PARTICIPATE
IN THE RECALL ELECTION. AND SO
THEREFORE THEY THEY SHOULD BE
ADDED INTO THE VERY WELL THAT'S
THE YEAR. THERE WAS CONCERN
OBVIOUSLY ABOUT THE LENGTH OF
TIME AND YOU KNOW MANY STATES
DON'T GIVE YOU A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY DAYS WHICH IS ALMOST A
HALF WHICH IS A HALF OF A YEAR.
TO BASICALLY- DO YOU RECALL
PETITIONS AND WE SAW AN EXTENDED
PERIOD THIS TIME MAINLY BECAUSE
OF THE- COLD EVERYBODY BLAMES ON
CALL THAT AND THE COURTS AGREED.
AND SO AS A RESULT WE END UP
WITH ALMOST AN ALMOST A YEAR.
WELL OF TIME TO COLLECT
SIGNATURES AND THEY WERE. IS
THAT IF THERE ARE FLAWS IN THIS
PERSON'S- PERSONALITY. FLAWS IN
HIS BEHAVIOR OR HIS SERVICE-
THOSE ISSUES SHOULD BE RESPONDED
TO ALL RIGHT AWAY AND NOT. TAKE
ANOTHER ALMOST A YEAR OF WORK
YOU CAN IN A BAG WAY MORE AND
MORE ISSUES IN APPLE'S ISSUES
TO. THE RECALL SO THERE'S A
CONCERN THAT ARE PART TIME
FRAMES ENTIRELY TOO LONG-
EVERYONE. SUPPOSED US. CREASING
FEES AND- M. SIGNATURE PRESSURE
. FOR FOR THE GOVERNOR TO. FOUR
FOUR. CANDIDATE AND THAT BECAUSE
PEOPLE FELT VERY STRONGLY THAT
THE PUBLIC CITY STAFF ACCESS. TO
THE RECALL. SHOULD BE REASONABLE
BUT IT SHOULD. HAVE ACCESS TO
THE RICO. BOB THIS YEAR- SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE MAIN
THINGS THAT FOLKS HAD A- IS A
CONDITION. OF THAT CONCERN OF
WHETHER THERE'S- THAT WE HAVE
DONE IN. INTO ABOUT. PROCESS WE
REGARD TO PROCEDURES THE SHOULD
BE. CALL WE CAN'T. WHO ALL THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS ARE OURS ARE
EXTREME IMPORTANT ISSUES- AND
THAT'S A SAY AN SHOULD BE.
EFFORTS TO DRIVE REALLY THE KIND
OF RECALL THAT WE WILL TO HAVE
AND THE- THIS YEAR- WE- THINK
CAUTION. THIS THAT. FACTOR
ACOSTA ALWAYS A- BUT IT SHOULD
NOT BE AT A POINT WHERE. FEEL
THAT- DONE RIGHT. AND SO- WE'RE
NOT WE'RE NOT ARGUING THAT THE
COST BACK TO BACK TO THE YEAR.
BUT WE ARE ARGUING SOME OF THE
OTHER ISSUES- THAT MAYBE HAVE
DIFFICULTY. I UNDERSTAND IT NOW
BUT I'M SURE TO OUR CALLS BACK
TO BECAUSE IT WAS INTERESTING-
DURING THIS LAST RECALL
ELECTION. WITH THE NUMBERS WILL
BE OUT TO DATE OUR STAFF IT'S
BEEN WORKING SO LATE LAST NIGHT
THIS MORNING TO VERIFY ALL OF.
THE MATERIALS THAT CAME IN. THE
LEGISLATURE ITSELF- MADE
POSSIBLE EIGHT AN ALLOCATION OF
TWO HUNDRED I THINK IN SEVENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE
RECALL PROCESS- AND- AND AS A
RESULT INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH. THE
ONLY WE SPENT A HUNDRED NINETY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS ON THE
RECALL SO WE- WE WERE- WE MADE
GOOD ON YOUR INVESTMENTS WE DID
NOT. THE WHOLE TUNE IN SO THE
SPEECH WAS NOT SPENT. UP THERE
WAS A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION- THAT WAS COUNTY COST
AND A HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
MILLION. THAT WAS SECRETARY OF
STATE COST- THERE'S STILL SOME
COUNTIES THAT HAVE- NEEDED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THERE ABOUT
SIXTEEN OF THEM BECAUSE THEY
COULD NOT- BASICALLY PULL OFF
THE ELECTION WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. AND YOU'LL GET THOSE
IN A REPORT AS IT COMES FORWARD-
THAT TURNED OUT OF COURSE AND
ELECTION WAS TWELVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION INDIVIDUALS. ABOUT IT.
WHICH WAS A COST OF ABOUT
FIFTEEN POINT. FIFTEEN DOLLARS
LITTLE TO FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER
PERSON. THAT WE PAY FOR THE
ELECTION- THERE WERE THERE WERE
TWENTY TWO ELIGIBLE REGISTERED
VOTERS- AND WHICH IS GAY AT ALL
HOLD IT BUT WE DID OUTREACH TO
ALL OF THEM WHICH MEANS THE COST
WAS. EIGHT HUNDRED NINETY SIX
DOLLARS. AND NINETY TWO DOLLARS
PER VOTER AND THAT WAS THE
RESULT- RECALLS ARE EXPENSIVE.
AND ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
IS THAT WHEN WE DO WE CALL THAT
WE GET IT WE DID IT THIS TIME
THAT WE- OPERATE THAT THE STATE
PAYS FOR IT- IT HASN'T ALWAYS
BEEN THAT WAY BUT IT IS IF
THERE'S A RECALL ELECTION
STATEWIDE. IT SHOULD TELL THE
STATE SHOULD PAY THE COSTS OF
THAT WAS. STRONGLY FELT BY THE
PERSONS AT THE COUNTY LEVEL. AND
THEY WERE GRATEFUL FOR OBVIOUSLY
FOR- FOR YOU. BEING ABLE TO DO
THAT- JUST IN TERMS THE- ASK. OF
IT. THE TO. OF ASPECT OF IT IS
THAT. IT IS VERY DIFFICULT. A TO
RUN INTO LAW OR ELECTION SUCH A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME- AFTER WE
WENT THROUGH THE WHOLE PROCESS
OF COLLECTING SIGNATURES
VERIFYING SIGNATURES THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT INDICATING THAT
THERE'S ENOUGH MONEY OTHER WAS
ENOUGH SIGNATURES OBVIOUSLY PUT
THE RECALL. WE HAD DID
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR HAVE BETWEEN
EIGHTY TO SIXTY DAYS- TO
BASICALLY CALL THE ELECTIONS.
ELECTION OFFICIALS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE'S SIMPLY BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS A BIT MUCH MORE TIME IS
NEEDED TO ADMINISTER AN ELECTION
IN A STATE THE SIZE OF
CALIFORNIA. UNCERTAINTY AFTER
THE ELECTION DATE PREVENTS
PRINTING BALLOTS AND VOTER
GUIDES AND OTHER REQUIRED
MATERIALS UNTIL SHORTLY BEFORE
AN ELECTION GETTING-
UNFORTUNATELY WE ONLY HAVE FORTY
SOME ODD FORTY THREE FORTY FOUR-
PERSONS ACTUALLY RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR I THINK THE LAST TIME
WAS A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SOMETHING. TO TRY TO PRODUCE A
DOCUMENT WITH THE INFORMATION ON
ALL THOSE INDIVIDUALS IN THAT
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME IS
DIFFICULT AND RUNS THE RISK OF
LAW ERIS- RUNS THE RISK OF THE
PAPER SHORTAGE AS WE I HAVE OF.
WHAT ABLE TO MEET THAT BUT
WEREN'T SURE INITIALLY WE WOULD
DO THAT BE ABLE TO MEET THE
PAPER SHORTAGE THERE'S A PAPER
THAT THERE'S A SPECIFIC PAPER
THAT THE BALLOTS ARE PRINTED ON.
AND TRYING TO MEET ALL OF THAT
AND NAVIGATE THAT AS WELL AS WE
HAVE OVERSEAS BORDERS THAT WE
MAILED BALLOTS TO ANOTHER FEMALE
EVERYONE A BALLOT IN CALIFORNIA
IT MAKES IT- A VERY MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT PROCESS ONE IS
DIFFICULT TO MANAGE. IT ALSO
DOESN'T GIVE MUCH TIME- THE
CURRENT PROCESS DOESN'T GIVE
MUCH CAR IMPROPER PEOPLE TO
VETS- TO GET TO KNOW THE
CANDIDATES WHO ARE RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR THE WAY THIS IS SO
STRUCTURED IT'S ALL DONE AT THE
SAME TIME- AND AS A RESULT WE
DON'T GET A CHANCE THOUGH TO
BASICALLY. TALK ABOUT THE
QUALIFICATIONS THE ACCESS PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE A CHANCE TO ACCESS
AND FIGURE OUT WHO'S RUNNING
WHAT THE REAL ISSUES ARE IT'S
PRINTED IN A BOOKLET BUT IT BUT
WE DON'T HAVE THE ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS AMONG CANDIDATES FOR
THE LARGEST STATE IN THE UNION
SO. WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT-
WOULD CONCERN AS A SAID ABOUT
THE COST AND A THE ASPECT IT IS
TRULY ONCE BACKED OUT WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PUBLIC KNOWS. WHAT THE
PROCESS IS. GOING TO- WELL THE
ISSUES WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT THE
PERSONS ARE. THAT ARE RUNNING A
WHAT THEY CALL THE- ARE ALL-THOSE KINDS OF THE- BECOME VERY
VERY IMPORTANT. TO THE PUBLIC WE
TALK ABOUT- REMOVING A GUN. OR
REMOVE ANYWAY FROM OFFICE. AND
YET W DON'T THAT TIME TO TIME
TO. IT TO ACCESS IT WE DIDN'T
MUCH AS WE COULD IN THE
SIGNATURES. OFFICE WE USED UP WE
UTILIZE A NUMBER OF- OF-
RESOURCES IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
MEDIA SOCIAL MEDIA AS WELL AS
MAILING THINGS OUT. TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE KNEW THAT THERE WAS
AN ELECTION UNDERSTOOD THE
PROCESS THEY VOTED TWICE. SO
FORTH AND SO ON BECAUSE IT'S
DIFFICULT WITH PEOPLE WITH A
PROCESS THAT YOU DON'T DO VERY
OFTEN. YOU TRY TO GET THE
INFORMATION OUT AS TO HOW THIS
PROCESS WORKS. SO IN IN THE YEAH
LET ME JUST SAY THAT- THERE'S
SOME CONSENSUS THAT THE
STRUCTURE IN THE LONG TERM
REFORM DESERVES PERIODIC REVIEW
AND WIDE RANGING. AND PROLONGED
SCRUTINY- THE RECOMMENDATION
OFTEN IS THAT WE SHOULD PROBABLY
HAVE SOME KIND OF COMMITTEES-
EVEN MY OFFICE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE OR THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT PERIODICALLY
EVALUATES THE RECALL PROCESS. OF
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S ALL THAT
WE STILL. ARE ABLE TO DO THE
KINDS OF THINGS WE SAY WE CAN DO
WITH THE RECALL TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE DONE THE NEXT LEVEL
TO PERFORM IF THERE'S ANYTHING.
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE BUT TO
TAKE TIME TO FULLY ASSESS WHAT
THE SYSTEM IS BUT- WHETHER IT'S
BROKEN AND IF SO. WHETHER IT
NEEDS FIXING AND- AND IT WAS NOT
THE FIXING IS BETTER THAN. OF
THE PARTS THAT WE HAVE A WHERE
THE NOT THIS IS JUST A BLOCK
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE TO LIVE
WITH- SO MUCH THAT CONSIDERED IN
HIS COMMITTEE THAT WE DO
SOMETHING LIKE SELECT COMMITTEES
AND INDEPENDENT CITIZENS
COMMITTEES AND REFUSED. TO PRINT
OUT TO KEEP US UP TO WHERE WE
ARE WITH REGARDS TO RECALL. BUT
ALSO WITH OTHER ISSUES. MANY OF
THEM HAD TO ISSUES WITH THE
WHOLE INITIATIVE PROCESS. THAT
IS IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW- SO
MANY ISSUES ABOUT- ST. IN TERMS
OF WHETHER OR NOT THE RECALL
PROCESS AS WELL AS THE PETITION
PROCESS. AND SIGNATURE
GATHERING. LIVES TO EXPECTATION
. YOU KNOW WE- WE DIDN'T
EMBARKED UPON THIS WHOLE
PETITION ISSUE. FROM THE PUBLIC
BECAUSE WE FELT THE PUBLIC
NEEDED A VOICE. AND THE RECALL
PROCESS TO THE PUBLIC NEED A
VOICE. BUT THE IS COMPLICATED
AND DIFFICULT IT IS NOW ALMOST
EVERYONE AGREES. THAT IT BECOMES
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE FOR AN AVERAGE
PERSON. TO ENGAGE IN
ESTABLISHING OR DOING A RECALL.
IT REQUIRES A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF RESOURCES AND MONEY. AND
OFTENTIMES OUTSIDE INFLUENCES
DETERMINES THE NATURE RECALL AS
WELL AS THE NATURE OF PETITIONS
THAT WE SEE. IN TERMS OF
LEGISLATION. SO NOT ALWAYS-
UNTIL THERE IS GREAT CONCERN
THAT WE HAVE NOT DONE ENOUGH AND
MAYBE WE CAN'T. TO BASICALLY A
PROBE INTO THE ACT I LOOK
FORWARD TO WHAT DO YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS WOULD BE- I
WOULD WANT TO CAUTION ALL OF US
THAT DOWN. THAT WE HAVE A
TREMENDOUS RESPONSIBILITY DID
NOT. RUSH TO JUDGMENT TO NOT RUN
QUICKLY TO. THE SOLUTIONS WHAT
TO SERIOUSLY LOOK AT THEM TAKE
THEM INTO CONSIDERATION. AND
REALLY BEGAN TO WORK TO SEE IF
THERE IS A WAY. THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE A STRONG A PROCESS
ONE THAT THE PUBLIC SEES IS
BEING FAIR. TO IT NOT ONLY TO
THE PERSON BEING RECALLED BUT TO
THE PUBLIC ITSELF AND IT REALLY
IS THE VOICE OF THE PUBLIC. AND
MANY FELT THAT THIS LAST PROCESS
WAS NOT- THAT DIED IT WAS AS I
SAID IT DID NOT GIVE THEM THE
ASSURANCE. BACKED UP IF THEY
RECALL THE GOVERNOR THAT THEY
WOULD BE ACTUALLY SELECTING A
REPLACEMENT. ALL AND THEY WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT ALL OF THAT AS
WELL AS THE- THE FACT THAT
THERE'S NO GOOD THERE WAS NO
RATIONALE THEY COULDN'T COME UP
WITH THE COST FOR THE RECALL.
THEY FELT THAT THEY WAS OUT. OF
SO MANY THINGS THAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN IT COULD HAVE BEEN DONE.
DIFFERENTLY THAT'S THE- WE.
WELCOME YOUR INPUT WE'RE LOOKING
. SOMETHING ALSO AND THREE AT
SOME POINT THIS HAVE A- TO WORK
CONTINUE WORK WITH YOU. ON VERY
ISSUE CALIFORNIA WHICH IS TO
BREAK. BY YOU SO MUCH. SECRETARY
WEBER THANK YOU FOR THAT
INCREDIBLY THOROUGH. THOROUGH
RUN DOWN I THINK I CAN SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF. BOTH COMMITTEES AND
SAY THAT WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
SPENT IN LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE
FROM. ALL THE VARIOUS ANGLES
THAT YOU JUST PRESENTED. TO US.
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO OPEN
IT UP TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR.
ANY QUESTIONS. GLAZER THANK YOU
CHAIR BRYANT. SECRETARY WEBER AS
THAT JEFF BRIAN INDICATED THANK
YOU FOR THE THOROUGHNESS OF YOUR
REVIEW. CERTAINLY OUR
APPRECIATION TO CHIEF JUSTICE.
RON GEORGE THE GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN AND THE MANY PEOPLE IN
WHICH SHE CONSULTED WITH. TO TO
BRING THE- THE THOUGHTFULNESS
THAT WE HAVE COME TO EXPECT FROM
YOUR OFFICE IN FROM YOU. SO-
MUCH APPRECIATED. SO IF YOU WERE
IN CHARGE TODAY. AND YOU HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY PUT FORWARD TO THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA A CHANGE OR
NOT. WHAT WHAT SPECIFICALLY
WOULD YOU RECOMMEND THAT GO
<c.cyan>ORWARD TO THE VOTERS ON THIS</c>
ISSUE. YOU KNOW- I PERSONALLY IS
AS I LOOK AT IT IN AND TRY TO
BRING A SENSE OF FAIRNESS WITH
THAT I SURELY WOULD NOT- I WOULD
I WOULD DEFINITELY MAKE SURE
THAT- THAT THE RECALL QUESTION
BOB WOULD BE A SINGLE QUESTION
ON THE BALLOT SHOULD WE SHOULD
WE NOT RECALL THE GOVERNOR. I
THINK IT BECOMES CONVOLUTED WHEN
YOU ADD NAMES TO THE LIST AND
YOU HAVE ALL OF THE FOLKS
RUNNING AT THE SAME TIME- PEOPLE
ARE NOT EVALUATING IS THERE
SOMETHING WRONG THAT WE NEED TO
DO RECALL ABOUT AND WHAT ARE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES IT'S ALWAYS
BECOMES IS THIS PERSON BETTER
THAN THE OTHER FORTY THREE AND
THAT BECAME THAT THE
CONVERSATION MUCH MORE THAN THE
DISCUSSION OF RECALL- SO I WOULD
DEFINITELY WOULD SEPARATE THAT.
I WOULD LOOK VERY CAREFULLY AT
THE SPANISH THE RECALL YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT ARE THE EXPECTATIONS
WHAT ARE THE STANDARDS AND HOW
DO WE EVALUATE INCLUDE EVALUATE
WHAT THE APP IS BEEN PROFICIENT
EVIDENCE AND INFORMATION TO PUT
IT ON THE BALLOT FOR RECALL
THOSE THINGS I THINK ARE
IMPORTANT BECAUSE CONSISTENTLY I
WAS ASKED AS I WENT AROUND AND
NOT DOING THE RECALL PROCESS IS
WHY ARE WE DOING THIS WHAT ARE
THE PERSON WHO DOES WRONG I KNOW
AND IT BECOMES VERY YOU KNOW
DIFFICULT TO ANSWER BECAUSE OF
THE FACT. THAT THE- THE
ALLEGATIONS ALL THE ISSUES OF
WRONGDOING WOULD NOT VERY CLEAR
AND THEN PEOPLE WORK GREATLY
CONCERNED- AT THE END OF THE
PROCESS AND I SAID THE ONLY
THING I CAN ENSURE TO MOST FOLKS
IF THE GOVERNOR'S RECALLED IS
THAT WE WOULD END UP WITH
SOMEONE WHO DID NOT HAVE THE
MAJORITY INTEREST OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND I SAY THAT
BECAUSE IT WAS CLEAR THAT WE
WERE GOING TO HAPPEN IS WE
DIDN'T EVEN WHAT'S WHAT'S NEXT
GET FIFTY PERCENT. ONE AND WE
DON'T HAVE A RECALL AND WE DON'T
HAVE RUNOFF PROCESS ANYTHING OF
THAT NATURE I KNOW TO TEN A
GOVERNOR IS NOT EXCITED ABOUT TO
STEPPING INTO THAT ROLE BUT THE
REALITY IS THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR. AS A FEEL
SAFE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE SOMEONE
WHO IS PREPARED TO SET
EXPERIENCE WHO CAN STEP INTO
THAT ROLE AND WHEN YOU PICKED A
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR- YOU SHOULD
BE PICKING SOMEONE YOU BELIEVE
WILL STEP INTO THAT ROLE OF THE
SAME IS TRUE I THINK WITH THE-
AND SOME ARGUED AND I WOULD
PROBABLY SAY IF THERE'S APPEARS. TO BE A CONFLICT THEN MAYBE WE
NEED TO HAVE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
AND GOVERNOR ON. THE SAME TO. SO
THAT YOU KNOW WERE YOU'RE BY. UP
FRONT AND THERE PEOPLE WHO MAKE
IT JUST. COULDN'T UP A- IS. ON
THE BILL. Y. KNOWING TO THEY
KNOW. WHAT THEY CHOSEN. AS A
SECOND. SO I THINK THOSE ARE
THE- IS. SAID THERE. IF WE CAN
LOOK AT THE TIME FRAME. I WOULD
DO THAT. I MAY WILL ALSO. THE
NUMBER OF TIMES PEOPLE CAN DO
RECALLS IT WAS SAYING THIS AND
THAT IT. TOO MUCH IT AT THAT AT
OUR LEVEL. BUT AT OTHER LEVELS
WORK THE FIRST TIME YOU DON'T
GET THE SIGNATURES COME BACK
AGAIN THE SECOND TIME YOU COME
BACK AGAIN A THIRD TIME. AND IT
BECOMES JUST THE OF THE WORLD
RECALLS IN IN TERMS OF OUR
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS AND UP- IF
THEY RECALLS A PERSON HAS A-
LEGITIMATE REASON TO DO THE
RECALL SHOULD BE DONE IT SHOULD
BE PUT OUT THERE. AND THEN WE
CAN TALK ABOUT- LOOK UP YOU KNOW
WE CAN DIDN'T ENGAGE IN THE
PROCESS. IT IS ALSO GOOD
SUGGESTED THAT WE DO A THAT IF
WE GO DOWN THE PATH WHERE- WITH
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
ACTUALLY BECOMES THE GOVERNMENT
THERE'S A RECALL. THAT THAT
PERSON THAT THE ELECTION TO
CHOOSE A GOVERNOR HAPPENS AT THE
NEXT STATEWIDE ELECTION. WHICH
MEANS IT COULD BE ALL ON AND OFF
YEAR IT COULD BE- WHENEVER WE'RE
DOING A STATE ELECTION THAT
WOULD PREVENT US BY HAVING SUCH
AN EXTREME COSTS. FOR ANOTHER
STATEWIDE ELECTION TO CHOOSE THE
GOVERNOR. OF THE STATE IT WOULD
BE BLENDED IN WITH THE NEXT
ELECTION SO. IF SAY FOR INSTANCE
IF FOR SOME REASON THE NEW SOME
HAD BEEN RECALL THIS TIME-
COLLECTORS WOULD BECOME
GOVERNOR. AND SHE AND THEN WE
WOULD HAVE ON ELECTION IN JUNE
OF THIS YEAR. OUR PRIMARY FOR
THE GOVERNOR AND THEN THE
GENERAL ELECTION AND WOULD ALLOW
IT SHE WANTED TO RUN. FOR THAT
SEAT BUT AT LEAST WE WOULD NOT
INCUR AN ADDITIONAL COST. TO TRY
TO FEEL THE GOVERNOR'S SAT FOR
A FEW MONTHS. AND AND UP BECAUSE
WE'VE ALREADY VOTED THERE ARE
REPLACEMENT. IS THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR WE DID THAT WHEN WE HAD
THE GENERAL ELECTION. AND IT
WOULD HOLD TRUE THAT THIS WOULD
BE A REPLACEMENT. UNTIL WE HAVE
ANOTHER ELECTION BUT WE WOULD
NOT HAVE TO HOLD OFF UNTIL THE
NORMAL CYCLE THE GOVERNOR'S
ELECTION. IT WOULD BE THE NEXT
STATEWIDE ELECTION. THOSE ARE
THINGS I THINK ARE A REASONABLE-
AND GET US TO THE POINT WHERE WE
CAN BE PROUD OF OUR- OUR RECALL
PROCESS. THAT BE FAIR TO THOSE
WHO WERE. MORE INTERESTED IN.
THE GOVERNOR. WILL BE FOR TO
THOSE WHO ARE. THE OF THE GUY.
WHO'S BY TO BE REACHED. AND TO
BEGIN. A GOOD. TO THE- IN TERMS
OF KNOWING- THAT THEY- MADE A
DECISION TO RECALL BASED ON THE
STANDARDS THAT THEY HAVE. AND
THAT THEY RECALL THE PERSON.
KNOWING THAT THEY'VE ALREADY
CHOSEN REPLACEMENT WHEN THEY DID
THE FIRST ELECTION. AND THEN IT
WOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO.
CHECK THAT THE SELECT THE
GOVERNOR. I MEAN THOSE ARE
THINGS I THINK THAT ARE.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE
OUR PROCESS IS FIGURE. OUT FOR
ALL THAT TO THAT ARE ALL
INTERESTED IN THE PROCESS. THANK
YOU US SECRETARY LEVER FOR YOUR
THOROUGHNESS AND YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS- AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AS
THE PROCESS GOES FORWARD. THANK
CHAIR RIGHT. YES A MEMBER BEEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR BRIAN-
SECRETARY WEBER I'M- I'M I'M
VERY IMPRESSED WITH THE
THOROUGHNESS ALSO. OF YOUR-
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND
PARTICULARLY. IN RESPONSE TO THE
QUESTIONS FROM SENATOR GLAZERS
WHAT WOULD YOU SPECIFICALLY
FOCUS ON- I'D LIKE TO ASK. WITH
REGARDS TO THE ISSUE OF.
COMBINING THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR WITH THE GOVERNOR. BOTH
IN THE ORIGINAL ELECTION LIKE WE
DO AT WITH THE UNITED STATES.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- THAT WOULD
ALSO HAVE THE ADVANTAGE OF. A
LIMON AIDING A LONG LIST OF
OTHER CANDIDATES ON THE BALLOT.
AND THEREFORE ADDRESS THE ISSUE
THAT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL YOU
IDENTIFIED AS A CONCERN WHICH IS
TRYING TO PREPARE. A BALLOT
PAMPHLETS XCERRA FOR FORTY OR
FIFTY OR SIXTY- CANDIDATES AND
GETTING ALL OF THAT- AND I WOULD
ALLOW. IT WOULD IT WOULD
ELIMINATE SORT OF THE WHOLE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THEM SO. I
JUST WANT TO ASK YOU HOW
SIGNIFICANT DO YOU TAKE IT IS
THAT WE ADDRESS THE ISSUE. OF
THE CHALLENGES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL FOUR- THE CLERK RECORDERS
IN. VARIOUS CANDIDATES. IN
VARIOUS COUNTIES TO. NARROW THE
RECALL DE DOWN TO- MORE DO.
VALID VOTES FOR THE FOR THE L.
THE ELECTORATE- AND ALSO FOR THE
ADMIN. OF THE LAW. IT WOULD BE-
CLEARLY- A MUCH EASIER JOB TO DO
BECAUSE KEEP IN MIND WHEN WE
HAVE FOLKS WHO- FILING TO BECOME
TO RUN FOR THE REPLACEMENT. WE
HAVE TO GIVE THEM TIME FRAME FOR
THEM TO- PUT THEIR PAPERS
TOGETHER GET THEIR MATERIAL
TOGETHER GET THE MONEY TOGETHER
SO THAT YOU YOU'VE GOT A WEEK
TO. CONSULT AND SOME EVEN A LOT
LONGER TIME SO YES IT WOULD BE
EASIER BECAUSE NOT ONLY ARE
LEVEL BUT AT THE AT THE AT THE-
COUNTY LEVEL BECAUSE YOU HAVE
ONE QUESTION SHOULD YOU RECALL
THIS GOVERNMENT IT'S NOT. IT'S
NOT LIKE- YOU KNOW I DO YU LIKE
THESE PEOPLE THESE OTHER FORTY
PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE TO PRINT ALL
THIS MATERIAL FOR AND ALL THE
DOCUMENTS FOR AND ALL THE
CERTIFICATIONS AND EXAMINE ALL
THE THINGS THEY PUT TOGETHER-
THE QUESTION IS IT. POSSIBLE FOR
YOU SHOULD YOU RECALL THE
GOVERNOR AND- AND IT'S A SIMPLE
QUESTION AND BUT IT WILL ALSO
LEAD TO I THINK MORE
CONVERSATION AND DEBATE AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE TO.
EXAMINE WHAT THE QUESTION IS AND
WHETHER NOT IT'S A BALLOT ENOUGH
QUESTION FOR YOU TO VOTE TO
RECALL THE GOVERNOR RATHER THAN
HAVING ALL OF THIS STUFF PUT
TOGETHER AND A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME. THROWN AT THE PUBLIC VERY
QUICKLY AND THEN THEY HAVE TO
MAKE THESE CHOICES AND THEN MAKE
LIMITED THINKING STRATEGICALLY
DO LEVEL FOR THIS VERSUS THAT
THEN THERE WAS A WHOLE MOVEMENT
TO SAYS DON'T GO FOR ANY
REPLACEMENT WHICH WHICH
OBVIOUSLY COULD HAVE TURNED OUT
TO BE A COMPLETE DISASTER. AND
SOME PEOPLE DIDN'T I THOUGHT YOU
KNOW VOTING FOR ONE OF THE
VOTING AGAINST THE OTHER INSULT
SO IT REALLY WOULD SIMPLIFY THE
MATTER IT WOULD MAKE IT EASIER
AUG TWO AUG FOR PEOPLE TO MAKE A
DECISION. AND THEN IT WOULD MAKE
IT EASIER AND GOING FORWARD THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS NOT BEEN
RECALLED A GOVERNOR HAS BEEN
RECALLED A LOT OF THE OTHER BUT
WE WOULD HAVE A CLEANER AND A
FASTER PROCESS- AND ONE THAT
WOULD PROBABLY GIVE PEOPLE MORE
INFORMATION. THAN THE CURRENT
PROCESS WE HAVE. THANK YOU SERVE
TO WEBER ONE ONE FOLLOW UP
QUESTION TO THAT IF THAT IS. AN
IMPROVEMENT FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE- AT THE STATE LEVEL-
WOULDN'T MAKE SENSE TO CONSIDER
HAVE YOU GIVEN ANY THOUGHT TO AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL A WE ALSO CAN
HAVE. THE SAME PROBLEM WHICH IS
YOU CAN HAVE A RECALL M. AND YOU
CAN HAVE MULTI. OTHER CAN. TO
WHAT WHAT WOULD IT MAKE MORE
SENSE STE A LOW RE. AS A OTHER-
YEAH REMOVAL FROM OFFICE OR
SOMEBODY DYING IN OFFICE IN
OTHER WORDS USED TO LOCAL
PROCEDURE THAT EXIST RIGHT THEN
IF THE CITY COUNCIL REPLACES YOU
IF YOU DIE IN OFFICE THE CITY
COUNCIL SHOULD REPLACE YOU IF
YOU'RE RECALL FROM OFFICE RTHER
THAN HAVING YES- SAME CHALLENGE
OF HAVING ALL THESE OTHER
CANDIDATES RUNNING IN THE RECALL
BEFORE WE KNOW WHETHER WE'VE
RECALLED. AND THEN AS YOU
STATED- HAVING THE NEXT
AVAILABLE ELECTION BE WHEN THEY
ACTUALLY THE ELECTORATE VOTES TO
REPLACE THAT CITY COUNCIL
CANDIDATE OR SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
BECAUSE THAT'S RIGHT I THINK I
SEE THE GREATEST ABUSE OF THE
RECALL HAS BEEN HAPPENING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL- WE'RE- PEOPLE THE
RECALL EFFORT IS BEING DONE.
PURELY FOR NARROW POLITICAL
REASONS AND NOT FOR ANY OF
GREGIS- ETHICAL VIOLATION ON THE
HEART IT ON ON ON THE PART OF
THE CANDIDATES SO- DO YOU HAVE
AN OPINION ABOUT THAT DID THE
FOLLOWING THE SAME KIND OF
CONCEPT- THAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING
AT THE STATEWIDE LEVEL FOR LOCAL
ELECTIONS. BUT YOU KNOW I THINK
I THINK IT SHOULD- YOU KNOW THE
PROCESS OF REMOVING A PERSON
FROM OFFICE IS A VERY SERIOUS
THING AND- NOT ONLY FOR THE
PERSON BUT FOR THE GOVERNMENT
FOR THE STRUCTURE THAT'S IN HERE
AND THOSE WHO ARE IN THE PROCESS
IT WILL PART OF IT SO IT SHOULD
BE DONE TAKEN VERY SERIOUSLY AND
NOT DONE- OFTEN- I KNOW THAT-
I'VE SEEN GROUPS CASES OF ISSUE
WHERE THERE'S BEEN I DON'T KNOW
THE- RECALL OF THE PERSON WENT
OVER. WHICH TO ME IF YOU DIDN'T
DO IT THE FIRST TIME LT'S MOVE
ON AND SO I THINK IN ADDITION TO
THAT WE HAVE TO BEAT THIS SOME
GUARD WILL TO PEOPLE PUT OUT THE
DRAFT AT LEAST BEEN IN OFFICE
FOR YEARS BEFORE YOU CAN BE
READY CALL YOU HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING IN ORDER TO EARN A
RECALL AND SO- SO THOSE ARE THE
THINGS I THINK THAT ARE
IMPORTANT. SOME CITIES HAVE A
VARIOUS PROCESSES IN SAN DIEGO
WE HAVE LOST TWO DIFFERENT
MAJORS ONE JUST RESIGNED AND THE
OTHER ONE- NOT GUESS WHO'S BEEN
THIRTY NOW WE PASS WE WERE.
UNIQUE WEEK WE HAD THE WE'VE HAD
GOVERNOR UP. WILL LEAVE THIS. OF
VARIOUS. READ AND THE CHAIR OF
THIS CAN. BECAME THE BIG ACTING
MAY. I KNOW FULL WELL TONY. WAS
THE ACTING MAYOR FOR. AND IN-
TALK GLORIA GLORIA WAS AS NUMBER
BUT HE WAS. ME AFTER- TWELVE
CHILDREN LIVE SO THERE A PRESS
THAT'S- THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THAT'S THAT THE CITY. DO
THEMSELVES WITH THEIR C. COUNCIL
AND I THINK THEY'D CAN
STRENGTHEN IT PROBABLY BY MAKING
SURE. THAT IF THERE'S A RECALL
PROCESS THAT THAT'S A PART OF
BUT JOIN PEOPLE. DIED OR MAYOR
RESIGNS OKAY THAT'S SOMETHING
ELSE THEY HAVE A PROCESS IN
PLACE AND THAT THEY USE IN TERMS
OF. THE CITY COUNCIL OFFICERS
AND- ACTING MAYOR UNTIL THE NEXT
ELECTION AND SO FORTH AND SO ON
BUT- I THINK TRYING TO. PEOPLE
ARE CONCERNED THAT WE HAVE A
STANDARDIZED AND YOU GO FROM ONE
BOOK TO THE NEXT SOME CITIES
HAVE 20% FOR RECALL. SIGNATURES
OTHERS HAVE LESS- AND- AND I
THINK IT'S A NEW ONE IF CITIES
AS MUCH OF A TANAMI AND YOU
PASSABLY CAYENNE- TO MEET THEIR
NEEDS BECAUSE EVERY CITY IS VERY
DIFFERENT. AND YOU CAN'T DO A
LOT OF L. A. B. PROCESS WITHOUT
SUTTER COUNTY OR SOMETHING OF
THAT NATURE. THE SIZES ARE SO
DIFFERENT AND- SO DIFFERENT. BUT
I THINK WE SHOULD AT LEAST LOOK
AT THE PROCESS AND MAKE SURE
THERE'S CERTAIN THINGS THAT ARE
THERE ABOUT IT- IN TERMS OF.
HAVING A DINNER FIVE WHAT THE
SECESSION YES AND WHO COMES IN.
AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS- BUT
THEY MAKE IT SHOOTS OUT WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO WITH THE LOCAL
LEVEL BUT DOCTOR. ACTUALLY
HAVING SOME SOMETIMES FRAME AND
SOME LIMIT TO THE NUMBER RECALLS
THAT YOU CAN PUT. THIS ON ONE
PERSON. ALL THAT STUFF CAN BE
VERY DISRUPTIVE TO IF WE'RE
CONSTANTLY FALLING PAPERS FOR A
RECALL ON SOMEONE WHO JUST GOT
AN OFFICE. AND I'VE SEEN IT
RECENTLY SURE THE SUCCESSION
PROCESS IF IT IS A SUCCESSION
PROCESS. THAT IS FOLLOWED. IF
THE SAME SUCCESSION PROCESS IS
FOLLOWED FOR RESIGNING IS FALL
FOR RECALL IT WOULD. POTENTIALLY
DECREASED THE SAME CONFUSION.
AND CHALLENGES THAT. WE HAVE-
THAT WERE RICH REFER TO AS A
STATEWIDE LAW. WAS TEN A
GOVERNOR BEING ON THE BALLOT.
THANK YES THEY YES. THANK YOU
BENNETT I DON'T WEBBER I HAVE A-
THE ARGUMENTS MADE. IMPAR
COMMITTEE HERE THAT RICO A
REALLY WERE AND THERE'S NO NEW
TO CHANGE THIS QUO OR MAKE
MAJOR. AT FIRST COMMITTEE
HEARING YOU MADE A NUMBER OF
POINTS ABOUT THE FLAWS IN THE-
FULL THREE RECALL. AND I'M
CURIOUS WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE
ON THE URGENCY OF MAKING CHANGES
TO THE RECALL FOLLOWING LAST
YEAR AS WELL. I THINK IT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I THINK WE
CAN WE CAN SAY THIS THIS THIS
SITUATION ONLY HAPPENS ONCE
EVERY. YOU KNOW WE CAN INITIALLY
SAID IF THIS IS HAPPENING BUT
NOBODY'S BEEN RECALLED OKAY OR
THAT'S KIND OF THE CERTIFICATE.
THE NOT QUALIFYING FOR THE
BALLOT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE
MAKE DECISIONS NOW WHILE IT'S
FRESH IN PEOPLE'S MINDS. BUT
FORGOTTEN ABOUT THE RECALL INTO
IT AND IT'S IN A TWO THOUSAND
AND THREE IN FACT THEY TALKED
ABOUT HOW. THEY HAD CHANGES THEY
HAD IDEAS AND THEN THE
LEGISLATURE DIDN'T HAVE BEEN PUT
FORWARD DIDN'T GET TO THE BALLOT
SO WHILE IT'S ON THE MINDS OF
PEOPLE AND THEY KNOW WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. WE SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD WITH SOME DISCUSSIONS
AND POSSIBLY SOME SOME REFORMS
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO CHANGE THE
WHOLE SYSTEM SO THAT IT'S
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT TO WHAT IT
IS. BUT CLEARLY THE FLAWS THAT
WE SEE IN IT THAT EVERYBODY
AGREES TO THE ACTIONS EVERYONE
SOME FOLKS DON'T THEY SEE THE
FLOP THEY DON'T THINK IT'S-
LARGE ENOUGH TO MAKE CHANGE.
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING WE SHOULD
DO- AND MOST FOLKS THAT THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
AFTER TWO THOUSAND AND THREE AND
IT DIDN'T- AND- ISSUES- BOB. YOU
KNOW ISSUES OF QUALIFICATIONS-
WHAT IS QUALIFYING FOR PERSON TO
RUN ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
CAME TO MY DESK. AND WILL AND I
HAD TO NAVIGATE THE WITHOUT
HAVING ANY- ANY SUPPORT
NECESSARILY FROM THE LEGISLATURE
TERMS OF THEM HAVING WRESTLE
WITH THE SAME ISSUES BEFORE. AND
RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES SO WE'RE
I'M HOPING THAT THAT WILL THAT
THAT THE THAT THEY WOULD NOT BE
SO MUCH. LEFT UP TO CHANCE OR TO
WHO I WANTED TO PICK I WAS VERY
CAREFUL NOT TO CHANGE THE RULES
TO MUCH. OF THE MAINLY BECAUSE I
DIDN'T WANT PEOPLE TO THINK THAT
THIS WAS SOME MANIPULATION KIND
OF GOING ON. BUT ISSUES- OF
QUALIFICATIONS OF INDIVIDUALS
RUNNING AND ALL THOSE KIN OF
THINGS THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WE
JUST KIND OF LEFT OUT THERE AND
SO- AND THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE WERE
APPALLED AT WHAT THEY SAW
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR-
INTELLECTUAL BUT THAT'S WHAT OUR
FARMERS OUR SYSTEM DOES PRODUCE
AND SO- SO I THINK IT IS TIME TO
YOU KNOW THIS IS THIS IS A- IT'S
A IT'S A GOOD TIME TO DO IT
WHILE IT'S ON PEOPLE'S MINDS.
PEOPLE CAN VOTE AGAINST IT THEY
CAN BEFORE THEY HAVE TO.
CONSTITUTIONAL. CHANGE BUT I
THINK IT IS SOMETHING WE SHOULD
DO AND IS. NOT BE. SO THAT. I DO
. WOULD BEEN ONE OF TO HAPPEN.
BUT I IT MAY. BE I DON'T KNOW IF
. THE GROUP CAN LOOK AT FAST.
OCT AT LEAST WITH. THE OF TIME.
AND PRODUCE TIME CHANGED THE
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA WANT. TO KIND
OF HEAR. AND DISCUSSIONS THAT
YOU HAD. A TO DO THAT BUT I
THINK IT IS- WE SAW ONE A RECALL
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN- TOOK TWO
THOUSAND THREE WE SAW ONE THIS
PAST YEAR. AND SOMEONE SAID WELL
THAT'S WHAT EVERY FIFTEEN YEARS
BUT WHO KNOWS IT MIGHT BE
ANOTHER RECALL IN THE NEXT THREE
FOUR YEARS. A WE DON'T KNOW I
JUST BECAUSE IT WAS A HUNDRED
YEARS BEFORE THE FIRST ONE.
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY'LL BE
ANOTHER HUNDRED YEARS THEY MAY
BE ANOTHER. TWO YEARS THREE
YEARS WE DON'T KNOW- WE KNOW
THAT THE PROCESS HAS CHANGED SO
DRAMATICALLY. IN TERMS OF THOSE
WHO. WHO PUT RESOURCES AND MONEY
UP THE RECALLS- BECAUSE IT IS
EXPENSIVE VENTURE THAT IT MAY
HAPPEN MORE OFTEN THAN NORMALLY
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED. BUT JUST
THE OFFICES AND PULLING OUT.
SOME PAPERS TO DO A RECALL.
THANK YOU DR RAINY. FINAL
QUESTIONS ARE. FROM COME MEMBERS
. WITH THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR MAKING SOME TIME TO BE A
PART OF THIS JOINT LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS- WE'RE WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT YOU AND
YOUR TEAM PUT IN- AND I HOPE YOU
HAVE A BEAUTIFUL REST OF YOUR
DAY. THANK YOU BASED ON THE WORK
YOU GUYS DO AND I REALLY
APPRECIATED AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER ON THIS. THANK YOU
AND CERTAIN WITHIN A PASSAGE IN
GALATIANS. THANK YOU JEFF RYAN
THANK YOU SECRETARY WEBER FOR.
WONDERFUL INSIGHTFUL TESTIMONY
AND THAT WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR
NEXT SPEAKER. TO PRESENT TO ARC
JOINT COMMITTEE. HE HAS MARK
BALL THE SORRY. HE IS THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE HE HOLDS THE MILLER CHAIR
IN PUBLIC POLICY HE HAS DIRECTED
THE PP I SEE STATEWIDE SURVEY
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. YES
HE IS THAT OLD. I HE IS AN
EXPERT ON PUBLIC OPINION AND
SURVEY METHODS HAS HAD NUMEROUS
PUBLICATIONS ON ELECTIONS VOTER
BEHAVIOR. POLITICAL AND FISCAL
REFORM HE'S THE CO AUTHOR OF THE
BOOK THE COMING AGE OF DIRECT
DEMOCRACY CALIFORNIA'S RECALL
AND BEYOND. BEFORE JOINING THE
PP I SEE HE WAS A PROFESSOR OF
URBAN AND REGIONAL PLANNING AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IRVINE. WHERE HE HELD THE
JOHNSON SHARON CIVIC GOVERNANCE
HE HOLDS A PHD IN SOCIOLOGY FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT
BERKELEY. GO BEARS. DR BOB ALL
THE SORRY WELCOME TO OUR
COMMITTEE AND YOU CAN ARE. CAN
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU- THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT KIND INTRODUCTION STATE
. FIRST OF ALL LET ME JUST.
MANSION YEAH I SAY AND- WHERE
I'M PRESIDENT AND CEO WE'RE
DEDICATED CONFORMING AND
IMPROVING PUBLIC POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA. THROUGH INDEPENDENT
OBJECTIVE NONPARTISAN RESEARCH.
AND THAT THE PP I SEE STATE
RIGHT CERTAINLY WHICH BEGAN IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AND THAT'S
BEEN AROUND FOR BOTH HE TWO
THOUSAND THREE IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE RECALL- ITS PURPOSE
IS TO PROVIDE A VOICE FOR THE
PUBLIC AT LIKELY VOTERS
INFORMING POLICYMAKERS
ENCOURAGING DISCUSSION. LIKE
WE'RE HAVING TODAY AND RAISING
AWARENESS ON CRITICAL ISSUES OF
THE DAY BEFORE I GET STARTED I
WANT YOU. TO NOTICE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE HAS HAS LEFT-
BUT I LIKE I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE VERY LEADERSHIP
COMING IN AS AN APPOINTED
SECRETARY OF STATE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND THE FACED WITH-
THE CAST OF THE UPCOMING
ELECTION IN A LECTURE HERE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE RECALL. WONDER
WHAT KNOWLEDGE THEY LEADERSHIP.
AND IT CREATING A FOR AND A LOT
. IN WHICH WE FACE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT ELECTION. IN ANY
. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE RURAL
STARTED YOUR- I ENJOY SIXTH WITH
. AN INSULAR AROUND AT THE NASH
ELECTION AND INCOME PRODUCING AN
ELECTION. THAT COULD TILT UP
THAT THE PER AT THE LOTUS NOTES
ABOUT THE PROSPECTS- YEAH IF I
COULD ASK JUST AMONG COULD YOU
TRAIN YOUR CAMERA ON PLEASE- I'M
SORRY THAT. AS THAT. GIVE IT A
MOMENT HERE TO SEE TECH THERE
YOU GO WE'RE WE GOTCHA OKAY
THANKS PLEASE GOOD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SO AS I WAS
MENTIONING IT KNOWLEDGE IN THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE SECRETARY OF
STATE IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
LECTURES BUT I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE BOTH THE CHAIRS AND THE VICE
YEARS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
TAKING ON THE TASK OF- LOOKING
AT THE PROCESS IT TOOK PLACE IN.
AND ASSEMBLY OF MAKING HIM. ARE
WHICH IS NEVER AN EASY TASK BUT-
BUT AN IMPORTANT ONE WORD ROCK
C. AND WHAT OUR TECHNOLOGY BOTH
THE CHAIRS AND VICE CHAIRS OF
THE TWO COMMITTEES. WHO ARE
ENGAGED IN THIS PROCESS I
PREPARE THEIR TESTIMONY FOR
THIS- FOR THIS PURPOSE. I WISH I
COULD MEET AGAIN TO ALL USERS
UPON EARLY SURVEY. AND LET ME
JUST BACK UP FROM OF SOME- IT WE
HAD TO S. AS WE MENTIONED IN A
NUMBER OF TIMES WE'VE HAD TO
WAIT TIMES. AT THE END OF. FIELD
VOTE- AND GOVERNMENT RECALL. AND
YOU VERY DIFFERENT OUT IN
OCTOBER THOUSAND THREE GOVERNOR
GRAY DAVIS WAS REMOVED FROM
OFFICE AND REPLACED BY ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER. IN SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE GOVERNOR
NUISANCE REMAINED IN OFFICE WITH
THE 62% OF THE VOTE. TO RECALL
HIM THE OUTCOMES WERE VERY
DIFFERENT BUT I THINK I SEE
SURVEYS CONDUCTED. BEFORE AND
RIGHT NOW THE HE IN BOTH CASES
CENTERS SHOWED STRONG SUPPORT
FOR PROCESS CHANGES TO RECALL
ELECTIONS- WHAT WHAT. WHAT DO WE
KNOW FROM THE SURVEY CITY AND
THAT WE CONDUCTED RIGHT AFTER
THAT WE CALL IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. L. AND YOU'RE A VERY PRO
PROCESSES TWENTY ONE-
OVERWHELMINGLY- THIS PAST
NOVEMBER 79% OF LIKELY VOTERS
SAID THAT THE RECENT RECALL US
BASED MONEY STE ABOUT 70% ALSO
SAID THAT- CHANGES WERE NEEDED
IN THE RECALL PROCESS. STILL
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN
CONTACT SAID 86% OF LIKELY
VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA SAID THAT
IS A GOOD THING THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION PROVIDES FOR A TO
YOUR CALL STATE ELECTED
OFFICIALS SUCH AS GOVERNOR. SO
I'M GONNA TELL YOU TODAY ABOUT
OUR LATEST CONDUCTED FROM
JANUARY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY FIFTH
SO THAT ENDED ABOUT A WEEK AGO.
FINALLY READING ON SUPPORT FOR
POSSIBLE RECALL REFORMS ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO BALLOT NOT ALL
OF THEM BUT SOME OF THE- IN THIS
SURVEY HAS BEEN INFORMED BY
COMMON SIX SUGGESTIONS FROM A
NUMBER OF POLICYMAKERS AND
POLICY EXPERTS. BUT IT'S A
SURVEY METHODS QUESTIONS AND
CONTENT TO TERMINATE SOLELY BY
PP I STUDENTS. SO FIRST ARE
CALIFORNIANS TODAY IN TERMS OF-
THEY'RE YOU THINKING ABOUT THE-
THE RECALL PROCESS- THE LATEST
EXPERIENCED. AT 39% OF
CALIFORNIA VOTERS SAID THAT IT
MADE THEM FEEL WORSE ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA. POLITICS AND
ELECTIONS WHILE 18% SAID THAT IT
MADE THEM FEEL BETTER ABOUT
CALIFORNIA POLITICS AND
ELECTIONS 40% SAID DID MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. MARK REPUBLICANS
THEN INDEPENDENCE- I SAID THAT
IT MADE HIM FEEL WORSE THEN IT
HAPPENED AND- THEN IT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS 54% OF REPUBLICANS 49%
OF INDEPENDENCE. COMPARED 230%
OF DEMOCRATS SAID THAT THAT THAT
THE RECALL PROCESS MADE THEM
FEEL WORSE ABOUT. CALIFORNIA
POLITICS ELECTIONS. SO TO IT
INFORM HIS FAMILY. WE ALSO HAVE
AT THE REFORMS AND WE ASKED
ABOUT TO KEEP PROPOSALS THAT
THAT YOU. HEARD ABOUT THIS
MORNING- AND SOME SPECIFIC
PROPOSALS ON FIRST OF ALL THE
SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT. THE
SIGNATURE REQUIRED- ONE VERSION
OF THIS REFORM WOULD CHANGE HIS
SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT FROM 12%
220% OF THE TOTAL VOTES CAST.
ELECTED WITH FOR THAT OFFICE
CONTACTS AND IS A MEMBER RECALL
ELECTION ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
SIGNATURES WERE REQUIRED YOU TO
QUALIFY WE EXPLAIN TO VOTERS
THAT THIS CHANGE MEANT THAT HIGH
STANDARD BEING. TWO POINT FIVE I
- TODAY FIFTY PER 5% LIKE. WITH
MAY S. AS WE FIND WITH A LOT OF
CIVIC PRESSURE ABOUT AROUND
RECALL PERSON GROUPS WERE GET
KEEP DIVIDED ON SUPPORT FOR THIS
PROPOSAL 69% OF DEMOCRATS
COMPARED 222% OF REPUBLICANS.
AND 39% OF AND IN SUPPORTING
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL I ALSO
MENTIONED THAT- THAT THERE WERE
JUST 4% WERE UNDECIDED ON THIS
PARTICULAR. THOSE LAWS THAT HAVE
AN INTEREST PERCENT ACROSS FULL
OP RIPS ANOTHER VERSION OF
REFORM WHICH HAVE BEEN DESCRIBED
. WHICH WOULD EXPLAIN TO
CONGRESS WHAT CHANGING
REQUIREMENTS 10% OF ALL
REGISTERED VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA
. THIS WOULD HAVE MEANT TO POINT
MILLION REQUIRED SIGNATURES FOR
THEIR SEPTEMBER RECALL CURRENTLY
FORTY THREE PERCENT. THIS CHANGE
PARTISAN ONCE AGAIN DIVIDED BUT
AFTER THE JOURNEY ACROSS
PARTIES- NOT OF THIS BILL
PROPOSAL 9% DEMOCRATS 37%
REPUBLICANS AND FORTY FIVE
PERCENT. OF INDEPENDENCE ONCE
AGAIN- RELATIVELY SMALL NUMBER
WHO SAY THAT THEY HAVE NO
OPINION FIVE PERCENT- YEAH IN
THIS CASE 52% OF PUBLICLY VOTERS
SAYING THAT THEY WERE A POST. SO
THE MOVING ON TO A SECOND FORM
COVERAGE OF REFORM PROPOSALS-
HAVING TO DO WITH THE
REPLACEMENT PROCESS- IN ARTICLE
HE- LAST YEAR WE FOUND A NUMBER
OF. LARGE NUMBER CALIFORNIANS
SAYING THAT THEY SUPPORTED
HAVING A TOP TWO RUNOFF- AND
INDICATING THAT IT THAT THERE
WERE SOME PROBLEMATIC HELEN
SPENT FROM THEIR STANDPOINT AND
THE SECOND PART OF THE BALLOT TO
REPLACE MY CLASSES SO WE- TESTED
IN THIS CASE A COUPLE OF VERY
SPECIFIC PROPOSALS CURRENTLY OF
MILLIONS ALREADY WROTE YES ON
PART ONE OF THE RECALL BALLOT.
THE GOVERNOR'S LOOKS MODEST IN
THE CANDIDATE WHO RECEIVES THE
MOST VOTES ON PART TO THE
POLICIES. THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
. SO WE LOOKED AT HER GOAL OF.
THAT SHOULD LEAD TENER GOVERNOR
OVER FOR THE RE OF THE FOUR YEAR
TERM. IF THE GOVERNOR'S RECALL
50% BYON A PRESENT SUPPORT THIS
CHANGE ONCE AGAIN PARTISAN TO
DEEPLY DIVIDED SIXTY SEVEN
SENATE DEMOCRATS 20% REPUBLICANS
AND 40% OF INDEPENDENTS TAKE
CARE. A SECOND FORM OF THIS-
CHANGING REPORT REPLACEMENT
PROCESS IS SIMILAR TO KEEP
PERCENT SUPPORT ACCORDING TO
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR TO GOVERNOR
AND HAVING A SPECIAL BALLOT
MEASURE TO REPLACE THE GOVERNOR
IN THE NEXT STATEWIDE ELECTIONS.
AGAIN PARTICIPATING PROVIDED 66%
DEMOCRATS 34% REPUBLICANS 43% OF
THE INDEPENDENCE- HIM IN BOTH OF
THOSE CASES FOR THE REPLACEMENT-
THE QUESTIONS OF WHAT. WHAT WE-
OF THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR POINT
OUT THAT THE- YOU KNOW THE
EVENTS ARE PLANNED. PLACE SMALL
PERCENT- AND SAID. SO THE LAST
NOT BE I WANT TO YOU I'M GONNA
TELL YOU ABOUT ANOTHER QUESTION
ASK ABOUT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
GOOD- RELEVANT THE WORK THAT
THANK YOU OUT- NINE- HOW
INTERESTED ARE LIKE. VOTERS THAT
INTO. CHANGES SURGERY. WHEN TOLD
THAT THERE IS A- HEARINGS I
THERE ARE TWO. THAT WILL MAY
RECOMMEND. THAT WOULD REQUIRE
APPROVAL 60% SAY THEY THINK IT
IS A GOOD IDEA TO HAVE STATE
PROPOSITIONS ABOUT THE RECALL.
PROCESS ON THE BALLOT THIS YEAR
. MAJORITY SAID LIKELY VOTERS
THE REGION ISN'T DEMOGRAPHICS
THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA. 72% OF
DEMOCRATS 55% OF INDEPENDENCE
AND 47% OF REPUBLICANS SAY IT'S
A GOOD IDEA TO HAVE RECALLED
WARMTH HELLO IS A LIST OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO ELECTION
BALLOT. SO WHY IS THAT SO. THE
GOVERNOR'S RECALL PROCESS
PROCESS ILLUSTRATES AND RUNNER
DILEMMA FOR A DIRECT DEMOCRACY
SYSTEM THAT ASK FOR VOTERS TO
WEIGH IN ON INITIATIVES
REFERENDA AND RECALL. WHEN I
WROTE A BOOK ON THE TWO THOUSAND
THREE THE CALL I NOTED THAT
CALIFORNIA VOTERS AND- ALMOST.
HAVE ALL PARTICIPATED IN IT.
GOVERNANCE'S THAT IS STILL LESS
THAN PERFECT. THE QUESTION IS
WILL THEY MAKE REFORMS NECESSARY
FOR MORE EFFECTIVE SYSTEM OR
WILL THEY A LOT OF THE SPIDER
AND PERHAPS EVEN FELT IN SOME
FUTURE. THE ENTIRE NAIL TO
PENTAGON HOW MUCH IS FOR ARE
WILL TO AT CHANGE. THIS YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE VOTERS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE ACTION OR
FOLLOWING THE SCRIPTS OF THE TWO
THOUSAND THREE RECALL THEY CAN
IGNORE THE WARNING SIGNS AND.
RISK POLITICAL CRISIS IN THE
FUTURE. YES RECORD TO IN.
DISCUSS ABOUT RECALL REFER.
EXPLORATION OR ASSESSOR. THIS
YEAR IN MEETINGS AS THIS ONE
TODAY. AND FOLLOWING RECALL
RECALL. THAT MAKE IT OUT TO THE
TWENTY TO ABOUT. GOOD RECALLS
ARE RARE AND STATE FROM. JUST TO
CHANGE THE CALIFORNIA CONCEPT.
ARE COMPLEX BUT THE IF
FUNCTIONING DIRECTOR IS A
SERIOUS MATTER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TALKED ABOUT THE SORRY FOR
THAT A WONDERFUL RESENTATION
AND FOR YOUR ON GOING WORK TO
PROVIDED PUBLIC INSIGHT TO OUR
POLICY MAKING HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE APPRECIATE IT
VERY MUCH. WE'RE GONNA GO FOR
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
HERE ON THE PANEL OF FIRST GOING
TO. TURN THE CHAIR BRIAN FOR HIS
QUESTION THANK YOU DON'T TALK
ABOUT A SITE THAT WAS.
INCREDIBLY INSIGHTFUL- AND AS
MINE COLLEAGUE IN THE SENATE
MENTIONED YOUR EFFORTS AROUND
THIS WORK NOW SPANNING. DECADES
DEDICATED TO POLLING OF VOTERS
ON THE RECALL AT I THINK OF
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD HAVE
INFORMED THE PROCESS EARLIER
THAN NOW BUT I'M GLAD WE COULD
UP LIFTED HEARING HEARING LIKE
THIS. YOU MENTIONED THAT GOING
FROM 12% 220% THE VOTER
THRESHOLD GOT 50% SUPPORT AND
THAT YOU EXPLAINED HOW MANY
TOTAL VOTES THAT CHANGE WOULD BE
FOR VOTERS. AND THE QUESTION
ABOUT GOING FROM 10% OF
REGISTERED VOTERS- FROM 12% IN
THE LAST ELECTION WAS THE%
NOMINAL CHANGE IN TOTAL VOTES
EXPLAINED BECAUSE THAT
RECOMMENDATION I'VE HEARD HAS
ALSO BEEN UPLIFTED BY THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION AND IT'S
GETTING SOME TRACTION AND SOME
CURIOUS TO WHAT EXTENT- IN YOUR
POLL. FOLKS WERE EXPLAIN KIND OF
THE BROADER FRAMEWORK OF WHAT
THAT WOULD MEAN IN TOTAL VOTE.
SO WE EXPLAIN IN TOTAL GROSS
WHAT WAS NEEDED IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND WATER WITH ME IF YOU
CHANGES TO- EITHER- THE TWENTY
PERCENT. THRESHOLD OR AT THE 10%
WE GAVE THE SPECIFIC NUMBERS.
WHICH IS THE POOREST MORE THAN
WHAT PROBABLY IN APPEARANCE A
BALLOT MEASURE BUT WE JUST FELT
THAT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE
THAT KIND OF CONTEXT- SO THAT
PEOPLE KNEW THAT IT MEANT THAT
THEY WOULD LET 10% ACTUALLY
MEANT BUT THERE'D BE MORE. OF
BOTH REQUIRED THEN AT 12% AND IN
THE PAST SELECTIONS- AND
SIMILARLY THAT 20% THAT. WOULD
BE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT MORE.
THANK YOU AND THEN AND THEN MINE
MY SECOND QUESTION AND ALL OF
THE POLLING THAT YOU'VE DONE
THROUGH THE YEARS ON THIS
PARTICULAR TOPIC. IS THERE ANY.
PARTICULAR PERSPECTIVE THAT'S
BEEN SHAED BY VOTERS THAT. YOU
FIND TO BE THE MOST SALIENT AND
MOST IMPORTANT FOR US TO REFLECT
ON FOLLOWING THIS YEAR. I DO
AND- IT DOESN'T GIVE YOU AN
ANSWER TO EXACTLY WHAT THE
PROPOSAL FUNDRAISER MOST WANT TO
HEAR BUT LAST YEAR WE ASKED THE
QUESTION IN ON NOVEMBER SURVEY
ACT OUT- IF THERE WAS A
COMMISSION- THAT WAS BIPARTISAN
AND HELD HEARINGS AND PROVIDED.
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH THE VOTERS
ABOUT DECIDE WE SAW A
CALIFORNIA LIKELY VOTERS MANY
DEMOCRATS REPUBLICANS AND
INDEPENDENTS AGREEING THAT THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT THEY THOUGHT
THEY THEY COULD SUPPORT AND THAT
THEY WANT TO SEE. AND SIMILARLY
IN THAT IN THIS CURRENT GOAL THE
60% WHO SIGNALED THE PROCESS
THAT YOU'RE GOING THROUGH NOW IS
SOMETHING THAT THEY WOULD- THEY
THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA IT. OKAY
THE SUCH AS YOURS PROVIDES SOME-
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WILL
THAT WILL VOTERS WILL BE ABLE TO
CONSIDER ON THE BALLOT LATER IN
THE YEAR WE SOUGHT NEARLY HALF
OF REPUBLICANS- SEVENTEEN TEN
DEMOCRATS MAJORITY LOOKING
DEPEND SAYING. THAT THEY THOUGHT
THAT WAS A GOOD IDEA. THAT MEANS
THAT- THE HARD WORK AND
LEADERSHIP THAT WE'RE SEEING- IT
IT THE EFFORTS THAT YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH TODAY OR SOMETHING THAT
THAT THE VOTERS WELCOME BECAUSE
THE VOTERS THINK VERY HIGHLY OF
THIS PROCESS- BUT HAVING TO
RECALL IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
THEM. THEY BELIEVE THAT IT'S NOT
A PERFECT ONE THAT'S CHANGES ARE
MADE EIGHT ARE NEEDED AND THEY
ARE LOOKING TO YOU FOR SOME-
SOME LEADERSHIP IN TERMS OF WHAT
COULD MAKE THIS PROCESS- ALL.
BUDGET AS THE FACT THAT WE AS
POSS. I CURRENTLY. THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BUT- THANK YOU FOR MUCH SIR. OF
I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS ON MY
SCREEN JUST POP GIVE ME ONE
SECOND THERE WE GO- AND THAT IS
YOU MENTIONED- A DOCTOR THAT IS
. GUBERNATORIAL RECALLS ARE
RARE- AND THAT WE'VE HAD BUT TO
WHAT EXTENT DO YOU THINK FROM
YOUR PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE
HERE IN THIS FIELD THAT PAID
SIGNATURE GATHERERS ARE LIKELY
TO MAKE RECALL ELECTIONS MUCH
LESS RARE THAN THEY WERE IN
THERE AND THEY'LL- OVERALL
HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES IN
OTHER WORDS ARE WE HAVE. IT
WHERE WE HAD A PERIOD WHERE
RECALL ELECTIONS ARE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO HAPPEN THAN THE
HISTORICAL. AVERAGE. I YEAH
THAT'S A HARD QUESTION FOR ME TO
ANSWER- AND- I THINK THAT ALL OF
. DEFERRED I EXPERIENCE THAT
THAT- I- COMMITTEE MIGHT HERE
THIS- BUT WE DO KNOW THAT THAT
THAT PAID SIGNATURE GATHERERS-
CLEARLY CHANGES THE DYNAMICS OF.
OF NATURAL RECALLS BUT REFERENDA
AND INITIATIVES WHICH ARE
ACTUALLY MORE COMMON. THAN
CITYWIDE RECALLS WE DO KNOW THAT
THERE ARE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
MANY MORE VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY- AND WHEN MANY MORE PEOPLE
WHO VOTED. SAID THAT WERE IN THE
PAST SO IT'S REALLY HARD FOR ME
TO SORT OF YOU KNOW MAKE AN
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT THE IMPACT OF
OUR PAID RECALL OF PAID
SIGNATURE GATHERERS EXCEPT AS
NAY THAT- IN IN MOST CASES WE
KNOW THAT. THAT THAT- ITEMS
GETTING TO THE STATEWIDE BALLOT
WITHOUT PAYING SIGNATURE.
GATHERERS WHAT. WITH WOULD BE
WITH RARE TO OF. THE MILLIONS OF
SIGNATURES ARE NEEDED TO MAKE
ABOUT. TO THE THAT A OF. RECALL
IS BAY ON TRULY ACT BY AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL WHICH-
HOPEFULLY WOULD MOTIVATE MANY
PEOPLE TO WANT TO SIGN THE
RECALL. IT IT TO. LEADS ME TO
THIS QUESTION AND THEN THAT I
GUESS OBSERVATION AND LIKE TO
GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT AND
THAT IS IF WE MAKE A CHANGE TO-
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR TAKING
OVER PROPOSALS THAT IS OUT
THERE. IT SEEMS THAT IT WOULD
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE
INCENTIVE FOR MINORITY
CANDIDATES TO FUND- RECALL
EFFORTS BECAUSE MINORITY
CANDIDATES WHO REALIZED THAT
THEY WOULD NEVER BE ABLE TO WIN
A MAJORITY VOTE AND A REGULAR
COOLEY SCHEDULED GUBERNATORIAL
ELECTION. VIEW THE RECALL
PROCESS AS A WAY FOR THEM TO-
TAKE THE SEAT- WITHOUT EARNING A
MAJORITY VOTE OF THE ELECTORATE
IN CALIFORNIA. IF WE MADE THIS
CHANGE THE LOOKS TENTATIVE
GOVERNOR ASPECT IT SEEMS TO ME
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THAT IT
WOULD DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE
INCENTIVE AND THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDS THAT WOULD FLOW BECAUSE-
YOU WOULD NOT HAVE THESE
MINORITY CANDIDATES IN THEIR
FUNDRAISING MACHINES FUNDING
HELPING TO FUND RECALL
CAMPAIGNS. IF THEY COULDN'T THEN
USE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME A
MINORITY ELECTED A GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA. COULD YOU OFFER YOUR
THE THIS SAGE OPINION ON THAT IF
YOU ARE WILLING RIGHT. HI I CAN
OPERATE AT WHETHER IT'S SAFE OR
NOT IT'S IT IS BASED ON WHAT
I'VE LEARNED ABOUT VOTER
INTEREST FROM THE DATE YOU
BECAUSE- TWENTY TWENTY ONE
GOVERNOR'S BASEBALL. I THINK IN.
IN S. SOMEBODY WHO DOES WORK IN
PUBLIC OPINION POLLING AND YOU
KNOW THE BIG QUESTION AROUND
ELECTIONS HE'S ALWAYS VOTER
TURNOUT AND- THE FACT THAT-
GLOBAL GOVERNMENT IS MEATBALLS
ARE SPECIAL ELECTIONS- THURS YOU
KNOW EXCEPT THAT RISKY
RECEPTION. THAT THESE COULD BE
LOW VOTER TURNOUT. ACTIVITIES
AND WE HEARD THAT AT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE RUN ELECTION WE HEARD
THAT THE THREE THOUSAND THREE
ELECTIONS THIS SUMMER DEGREE WE
WERE ARE WE UNDER. THE LEVEL OF
INTEREST. BUT ALSO THE- THAT
PEOPLE PLACE CUNNINGHAM CALL
BECAUSE THREE LAW AND I THINK
WHAT WHAT I LEARNED FROM THE
TWENTY. ONE A LOT. IS IF THERE
IS GOVERNOR BEFORE. THAT PEOPLE
ARE PEOPLE GOING TO. THE ISN'T
WORK AND THEY'RE GONNA GO LARA
NUMBER YEAH CANDIDATES WHO WOULD
EXPECT OTHERWISE I THINK WE'LL
BE SURPRISED TO LEARN. THAT THIS
IS ELECTIONS THAT WILL NOT JUST
GET GREAT MEDIA INTEREST BUT
THAT THE MOTORS WILL PAY A LOT
OF ATTENTION TO IN THE CASE OF
LAST YEAR- WHERE LOTS OF OTHER
THINGS WERE GOING ON COLD IT
CONCERNS ABOUT THE ECONOMY WITH
THE GROUND OUT US- THE RECALL
ELECTION. WAS CENTER STAGE
REPORTERS PEOPLE WHEN THEY THINK
VOTE IS IMPORTANT. AND
GOVERNMENT'S RECALLS. WE NOW TO-
WE WILL BE- PLEASANTLY SURPRISED
. AT MANY MANY HEALTH CONCERNS.
ABOUT THEIR- IN THE SELECTION.
AND THEY'RE GONNA SHOW UP. IN
YOUR YOUR POLLING DOES INDICATE
THAT. PEOPLE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
A MINORITY CANDIDATE BEING
ELECTED IN THAT RECALL PROCESS
CORRECT. YES AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO STEP BACK NOW YOU
KNOW THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
TWO THOUSAND THREE AT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE GREAT CALL WHAT'S
THAT IN BETWEEN THAT TIME-
CALIFORNIA WENT TO A- CHU
PRIMARY SYSTEM AS AS A PUBLICLY-
UNLESS THAT AND UNLESS
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ARE WELL
AWARE ACT. AND SO- AND VOTERS
SUPPORTED THAT THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT THAT THAT THEY
CAME TO THE BALLOT AND VOTERS
SAID WE WANT THE TOP TWO PRIMARY
SYSTEM WE WANT. THE PERSON WHO
GETS THE MAJORITY OF THE VOTES
TO BE ELECTRIC SO WHEN I ASKED
WHY CELESTE YEAR ABOUT- WHETHER
PEOPLE SUPPORTED A RUN OFF WITH
THE TOPIC I GETS LISTEN TALK TO
WHAT WE SAW SOLID MAJORITY
SUPPORT BOTH TIMES WERE.
CHANGING THE RECALL SYSTEM IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN CONTEXT
THAT THAT IS ALIGNED WITH WHAT
THE VOTERS SUPPORTED AT THE
BALLOT BOX WE WENT TO A TOP TWO
PRIMARY SYSTEM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BEEN. VERY HELPFUL REALLY
PUSHING THANK YOU. OTHER
QUESTIONSI REQUEST THINK YES
VICE. WE ARE JUST. I HAVE A CUP
OF QUESTIONS- WANTED ABOUT THE
SAME REQUIREMENT OTHER ONE IS
ABOUT- PROBABLY THE FINE PART OF
THIS- I- BENNETT HAS BROUGHT UP
A VERY. POINT ABOUT PEOPLE
TRYING TO ACCESS IT AND RUN IN A
RECALL ELECTION. AS FAR AS A
SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT EARLY ON
IN OUR HEARINGS WE HEARD IN MY
MIKE ON. OKAY THANK YOU- EARLY
ON IN OUR HEARINGS WE HEARD FROM
A PROFESSOR AT UC BERKELEY. WHO
HAD TALKED ABOUT THE SIGNATURE
REQUIREMENT AND HE MENTIONED
THAT. TAKING IT FROM 12% 220%
WOULD. TAKE SOMETHING THAT IS AN
ENDANGERED SPECIES IN HIS TERMS
AND MAKE IT EXTINCT AND IN OTHER
WORDS IT WOULD MAKE IT VERY VERY
DIFFICULT. BOTH FROM A FINANCIAL
AND PHYSICAL STANDPOINT FOR
PEOPLE WHO WISH TO ENGAGE IN A
RECALL PROCESS TO ACTUALLY
ACCOMPLISH IT AND THEREFORE
MAKING IT BE DISCOURAGING THEM
FROM DOING SO- WHICH IS
SOMETHING I THINK WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO GET AWAY FROM IS
DISCOURAGING PEOPLE FROM- THAT
PARTICIPATING IN THE VOTING
PROCESS. I DO AGREE WITH THEM OR
WOULD YOU DIFFER WITH THAT AND
IN SAY IT WOULDN'T MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT. TODAY IT'S EXTENT
SAID IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE. I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE AGAIN YOU KNOW WHEN
PEOPLE FEEL SOMETHING'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO DO HELLO DON'T TRY
TO GET THERE BUT I THINK THAT
THAT WOULD BE THE PERCEPTION OF
THE VOTERS SAID IT'S YOU MAKING
SOMETHING THAT'S DIFFICULT- MORE
DIFFICULT. AND I JUST WANT TO
YOU KNOW. RESTATE THE CONTEXT IN
WHICH THESE KINDS OF DECISIONS
ARE BEING MADE TODAY WHICH I
THINK IT'S OBVIOUS- THROUGH TO
ALL OF US WHO WERE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN TENSE HEARING
TODAY WE WERE WE LIVE IN A TIME
IN WHICH- ALEXION'S ELECTION
REFORMS ARE SOMETHING THAT THE
VOTERS ARE ARE HEARING ABOUT-
YEMENPRESS IN REPUBLICANS.
DIFFERENT TYPES OF ELECTION
REFORMS SO- I AMTHERE THEY'RE
FEELING ALL ACTION REFORMS AS
THROUGH ACCIDENTS LANCE AND-
THIS IS GOING TO MAKE THEM- I
THINK LOOK. VERY CLEAR AND
WHATEVER IS FARMS WOULD COME OUT
OF- COMMITTEE HEARINGS THEIR
WORK OR COMMISSIONS OR SIGNS
THAT THIS ISN'T ABOUT PARTY
TRYING TO GAIN ANY OVER THE
OTHER BUT THIS IS REALLY ABOUT-
THESE EASIER CAMPERS THAT ARE
BEING MADE. TO IMPROVE THE
FUNCTIONING OF DIRECT DEMOCRACY
IN CALIFORNIA TODAY SO WERE
REFORMS TO GET THAT KIND OF
SUPPORT THAT THAT THAT THAT-
THAT THEY WERE NEEDING
CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
CUTE **** REALLY IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE DEMOCRACY-
HANNAH'S FUNCTIONING- HIGH AND
PEOPLE WOULD BE LOOKING FOR
SIGNS THAT- WELL ALL THE PARTIES
INVOLVED AGREED THAT THESE
CHANGES ARE THE ONES THAT WILL
BE IN THE BEST INTEREST OF.
CALIFORNIA'S DIRECT DEMOCRACY
SYSTEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
- MY SECOND QUESTION RESULT
REVOLVES AROUND THE FINANCE PART
OF THIS AND- TO ENGAGE IN-
TRYING TO ATTEMPT A RECALL. TO
BE A CANDIDATE IN THE RECALL IS
EXPENSIVE AND THEY HAVE TO GO
OUT AND FUND RAISING THEY'RE
SUBJECTED TO- FOR CAMPAIGN
SPENDING LIMITS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT- WHEREAS A PERSON BEING ORG
RECALLED IS NOT. AND DOES SO
THEY HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO RAISE
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS VERSUS
THE DAVEY IN THE ROOM THAT GETS
A MILLION DOLLARS. AND IS THERE
ANY TALK ABOUT THAT TYPE OF
REFORM THAT WOULD HELP LEVEL
THAT PLAYING FIELD- SO THAT- IF
PEOPLE THAT ARE. AYE I MEAN SO
THE PERSON THAT IS BEING
RECALLED HAS THE SAME CAMPAIGN
LIMITS AS THE- PEOPLE THAT ARE.
TRYING TO ACCESS THE SYSTEM.
ACCESS THE VOTING- ALEXION
SYSTEM. I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO AND I HAVE NOT SEEN
ANY- YOU KNOW. PROPOSAL SO THAT
SOARED NOR. THAT IF THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT'S BEING SERIOUSLY
CONSIDERED- HUH I MAKING NOTED
LESS WORK FOR FUTURE POLLING
THAT YOU GUYS THINK RIGHT AND IT
THAT ANSWERED MY OTHER QUESTION
IS ANYBODY HAVE YOU RECALLED ANY
POLLING ON IT AND SO THANK YOU
FOR ANSWERING THAT. I COULD NOT
AT THIS POINT BUT IF IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S- BEING
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED YOU'RE MORE
ABOUT. INPUT THING AND- THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU- TO.
BYE SHARE C. R. TOO I
APPRECIATED IN PARTICULAR YOUR
FIRST QUESTION. BECAUSE IT
POINTED OUT THAT WE HAD A
WITNESS. TO OUR HEARING EARLIER
THAT WAS CRITICAL OF CHANGES IN
THE RECALL IT WAS SUGGESTED
EARLIER THAT SOME HAVE. THE
WITNESSES WERE INVALID SO I
APPRECIATE YOU RAISING THAT AND
REMINDING US OF THAT. OF THAT
TESTIMONY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FOR DR BARBARA SORRY. I HAVE
ONE- IN IN YOUR IN YOUR SURVEY
WORK THAT YOU DID IN NOVEMBER.
ONE OF THE FINDINGS OF A
QUESTION YOU ASKED IS THE RECALL
ON THE CHANGE. 50% OF THE PEOPLE
SAID MAJOR CHANGE 28% SAID MINOR
CHANGE TO SEVENTY EIGHT PERCENT.
AT THAT POINT IN TIME. I WANTED
TO ASK YOU OF. ABOUT THIS- THE
THIS TREND- EIGHT GIVEN THE
SURVEY WORK THAT YOU'VE JUST
COMPLETED IT SEEMS THAT THERE'S
LESS INTEREST IN RECALL THAT
THERE WAS IT EVEN HAS SAID
RECENTLY AS NOVEMBER AND
OBVIOUSLY IF THE LEGISLATURE WAS
TO PUT. ANY KIND OF REFORM ON AN
UPCOMING BALLOT IT WOULD HAPPEN
MANY MONTHS INTO THE FUTURE. CAN
YOU SPEAK THE WHAT YOU THINK
THIS MEANS OUR VOTERS-
DISTRACTED BY OTHER THINGS I.
DON'T SEE THE SAME URGENCY THAT
THEY SAW NOVEMBER HOW WOULD YOU
DESCRIBE. THE CHANGE IN MOOD AND
WHAT THAT MEANS GOING FORWARD.
THAT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION
SENATOR GLAZERS AND- DESERVE IT
WILL BE RELEASING THAT TOMORROW
WILL PROVIDE IN A CONTEXT THAT
WILL PRODUCE ARE TODAY BUT IT
THEIR CONCERNS BUT OBVIOUSLY
THEIR CONCERNS AROUND- OKAY THE
ECONOMY HOMELESSNESS- HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRYING- ALL THINKS
THAT I'M SURE THAT YOU'RE
HEARING ABOUT FROM CONSTITUENTS.
WHICH HAVE YOU KNOW TAKEN TAKEN
CENTER STAGE THIS YEAR AND- LAST
YEAR WHEN WE CONDUCTED OUR SUBS
YOU KNOW START FINAL POLLS I
DIDN'T MENTION THAT- YOU KNOW.
VOTERS WILL- YOU KNOW THIS
ELECTION HAVING AND THEN THERE'S
A RECALL HAVING THEN COMPLETED-
AND FOR- THE OUTCOME- MUCH TO
WHAT- YOU KNOW WE EXPECTED IN
THE POLLING THAT MANY VOTERS
MOVE ON OTHER CONCERTS- AND-
THAT I THINK IS. IT AS FAR IT'S
WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT THE CON IS
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
TODAY BUT I ONCE AGAIN I'LL
POINT TO THE FACT THAT SIXTY
PERCENT. SAID THAT YOU KNOW THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING THAT
HEARINGS THE POSSIBILITY OF
HAVING SOMETHING THAT THE VOTERS
CAN CONSIDER AND WEBER- IS
SOMETHING THAT- THAT 60% OF
VOTERS STATURE NAY SAYING IT'S A
GOOD IDEA- MAYBE IT HAD WOOD
WE'RE WOULD HAVE BEEN HIGHER. IN
NOVEMBER BUT THERE IS STILL LOT
OF VOTERS WHO RUN TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS PROCESS WHICH IS A NEW
THAT MICROPHONE ISSUES THEY
THINK THE IMPORT. OF THE OUTCOME
IS VERY GREAT CLERK FOR THE
STATE THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
THEY WANT TO BE SURE- IT'S BEEN
LOOKED AT AND IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED. NOW IS THE TIME TO PICK SIX.
THEY YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MARK BALD FOR TEST. AND FOR THE
ACTIVE ENGAGEMENT THAT PP I SEE
IN YOUR PAD IN OUR PUBLIC POLICY
ARENA GOING BACK FOR MANY
DECADES WE SO APPRECIATE. YOUR
EXPERTISE AND YOUR INSIGHT THAT
YOU BRING IT EVERY TIME WE HAVE
A CONVERSATION SO WE APPRECIATE
IT VERY MUCH THANK YOU. AND
WITHOUT ALL THE- HEARING BACK TO
CHAIR BRIAN. THEY GET YOUR
GLAZER AND ADDITIONALLY DOCTOR
BOX ART THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE- AND FOR YOUR INSIGHTFUL
DATA AND ALL THE WORK THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE DONE NOT JUST FOR THIS
PROCESS BUT FOR ALL OF THE
POLICY MAKING HERE WE DO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
TURN TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY. AND AS
A REMINDER WE SET ASIDE A TOTAL
OF ONE HOUR FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
STARTING WITH MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE. IN THE ROOM
ARE MINOR EACH PERSON WILL HAVE
ONE MINUTE TO MAKE THEIR REMARKS
. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ARE
UNABLE TO PARTICIPATE DURING
THIS PORTION OF THE GENDER WHO
HAVE LINKS YOUR THOUGHTS TO
SHARE. WITH THE COMMITTEES ARE
ENCOURAGED TO SUBMIT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY. WHICH WILL BECOME
PART OF THE OFFICIAL RECORD. OF
THE HEARING IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFIED BY PHONE THE CALL IN
NUMBERS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
IN THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR. TO WILL TO.
WE'LL START HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY. GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING. I HAVE ONE QUESTION AND
THEN I'LL CONTINUE WHEREBY THE
FREEDOM OF INFORMATION ACT CAN
WE GET THE SURVEY THAT HE'S
COMING TALKING ABOUT ABOUT THE
PERCENTAGE OF REPUBLICANS
DEMOCRATS LIBERTARIANS OR
INDEPENDENTS WHATEVER HE'S
TALKING ABOUT THE GUY THAT WROTE
THE BOOK ABOUT THE LAST RECALL.
WITH GRAY DAVIS. THAT'S WHAT I
WANT TO ASK THE COMMITTEE DO YOU
ANY OF YOU KNOW WE'RE THE
SURVEYS THAT I DON'T BELIEVE
YOU'LL NEED A FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT REQUEST I
BELIEVE PP I SEE IS GOING TO
ISSUE A BLOG POST TODAY. I AND
PUT PUBLISHED THEIR FINDINGS ON
THEIR ON THEIR WEBSITE AS THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE ON ON ON
THE STATE ON THE- ON ON HERE ON
THE STATE'S. WEBSITE OR THE
GOING TO BE IN THE VOTER
REGISTRATION OFFICES IN EACH
COUNTY. IT'LL BE ON THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA'S%
WEBSITE OKAY RIGHT I GET THAT
PARTISAN THING OKAY. I'M GONNA
EXPLAIN SOMETHING WHEN YOU
CONTINUE TO ASK ABOUT RAISING
THE PERCENTAGE OF THE RECALL I
MAY GO BACK TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE SHE SAID SUPPOSEDLY THE
CURVE IT. STOPPED AND WE HAD A
JUDGE APPROVED THE SECOND PART
THAT'S NOT WHAT HAPPENED SHE
SAID SUPPOSEDLY IT WAS EXACTLY
WHAT HAPPENED NOTHING WAS OPEN
WE WERE ALL ON LOCKDOWN
EVERYBODY WAS REMOTE YOU GUYS
WERE EVEN REMOTE. SO ALL OF THIS
BUT IT CONTINUES TO BE TALKED
ABOUT MEMBERS JIM AND IT
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT BUT HERE'S
MY LAST COMMENT THANK YOU KNOW
SCHOOL IS TEACHING FIT IN ORDER
KEEPING PEOPLE IGNORANT AND YOU
KNOW WHAT AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS MAX
BRUNNEA- AND I THINK THAT BY
MAKING STATEMENTS ABOUT THE
RECALL BEING UNDEMOCRATIC IN
NATURE YOU'RE BASICALLY SAYING
THAT ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER WAS
AN ILLEGITIMATE GOVERNOR. THIS
IS THE PROCESS WE'VE HAD FOR A
LONG TIME. SHIFTING AROUND THE
QUALIFICATIONS IN THE RULES
EVERY NOW AND THEN IS LIKE
BARRING PEOPLE FROM RUNNING. THE
FIRST QUESTION A SHELL EX
GOVERNOR TO BE RECALLED. AS LONG
AS A 50% PLUS ONE SAY YES THE
CANDIDATE WITH THE MOST VOTES IN
THE SECOND SECTION WHO SHALL
REPLACE EX GOVERNOR ASSUMES THE
OFFICE OF GOVERNOR. A PLURALITY
VOTE IS THE PROCESS WE USE IN
OUR PRIMARIES IT'S A PROCESS
USED IN THE UNITED KINGDOM AND
CANADA TO ELECT THEIR OFFICIALS
. WE ARE ONE OF NINETEEN STATES
THAT ALLOW CITIZENS TO RECALL
THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS. IF WE
TAKE THAT AWAY WE REMOVE
ACCOUNTABILITY FROM THE LOCAL
LEVEL ALL THE WAY UP TO THE
STATE LEVEL. THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION SAYS AND I QUOTE
RECALL IS THE POWER OF ELECTORS
TO REMOVE AN ELECTED AN ELECTIVE
OFFICER. MAX THAT'S ONE MINUTE
BUT THANK YOU I THINK IT'S
REALLY POWERFUL WHEN YOUNG
PEOPLE COME AND GIVE TESTIMONY
THANK YOU FOR THAT. BRIDE
PLASTER COUNTY IN THE WORDS OF
JIM NIELSEN FROM THAT THE
OCTOBER RECALL REFORM CARING CAN
WE LOWER THE MIKE FROM AS WE
GRAPPLE. LET GO. OKAY OKAY IN
THE WORDS OF JIM NIELSEN THANK
YOU JIM THE INITIATIVE AND THE
REFERENDUM AND THE RECALL A VERY
SACRED DIRECT DEMOCRACY
OPPORTUNITIES REALLY PERFECTED
IN THE STATE AND LET'S NOT
TRIVIALIZE THOSE I AGREE WITH
JIM NIELSEN THAT THERE IS NO
NEED TO CHANGE THE RECALL
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE
NINETEEN STATES PLUS THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA THAT
PERMITS THE RECALL OF STATE
OFFICIALS CALIFORNIA AND
COLORADO ARE UNIQUE IN RIO
HAVING THE RECALL AND REPLACE IN
ONE. ELECTION THIS SEEMS THE
MORE WE FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE
BEST OPTION LET'S PICK OUR
BATTLES LEAVE THE RECALL ALONE
WE DON'T NEED TO MAKE IT MORE
COMPLICATED AND EXPENSIVE BY
HAVING TO ELECTIONS. WE THE
PEOPLE NEED TO RETAIN OUR
EXISTING CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO AT LEAST
ATTEMPT TO RECALL STATE
OFFICIALS THE RECALL PROCESS IN
CALIFORNIA IS A WELL OILED
MACHINE. AND IT DOES NOT APPEAR
THAT SPENDING TAX DOLLARS
CHANGING OUR CONSTITUTION
REGARDING THE RECALL IS IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE PEACE
PEOPLE THANK YOU THAT'S ONE TALK
ABOUT ELECTION INTEGRITY LETTER.
WRITING ID MAIL IN VOTING AND
DOMINION MACHINES WE THE PEOPLE
CANNOT AFFORD TO SACRIFICE OUR
VOTER RIGHTS THANK YOU MS
MCBRIDE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. YES
SIR ORNATELY THE CHAIRMAN OF
REBUILD CALIFORNIA DOT COM AND-
I JUST WANT TO SAY THERE WAS
SEVEN ATTEMPTS TO RECALL ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER WHERE WAS YOUR-
YOU KNOW HIGHER THAN AND THE
RECALL PROCESS IS THE ONLY THING
LEFT THAT THE PEOPLE HAVE TO
HOLD YOU FOLKS ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE PEOPLE YOU WERE ELECTED TO
REPRESENT AND THE FARTHER YOU
WANDER AWAY FROM THAT OBLIGATION
AND FROM. YOUR YOUR FROM YOUR
THOMAS TO THE PEOPLE TO
REPRESENT THEM THE MORE YOU WISH
TO END THE RECALL PROCESS
BECAUSE IT IS THE ONLY THING
THAT'S LEFT TO HOLD YOU
ACCOUNTABLE SO I AGREE WITH
MISTER NELSON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR- SUPPORTING THE RECALL
PROCESS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOW
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. ARE THERE ANY
TESTIMONY STATION. HI GOOD
MORNING I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS RECALL
REFORM I KNOW THAT THE REFORM IS
A SLIPPERY SLOPE BECAUSE U. S.
B. FORMER RECALL. BUT I THINK
YOU HAVE YOUR OWN AGENDA TO
REFORM IT I THINK THAT WE NEED
TO KEEP OUR RIGHTS AS A SET IN
THE CONSTITUTION IS WE THE
PEOPLE NOT WITH THE GOVERNMENT
SO TO TAKE THAT RIGHT AWAY FROM
US BECAUSE YOU'RE AFRAID OF
SOME. PARENTS WHO WANT TO STAND
UP FOR THEIR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
IN OUR FREEDOMS. I MEAN YOU GUYS
SHOULD BE STANDING WITH US NOT
AGAINST US. SO THE RECALL IS OUR
RIGHT. WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO GET
THE GOVERNMENT OUT WHEN THEY'RE-
ADELINE IT'S UP TO US TO KEEP
THEM IN LINE. IS ALWAYS YOU GOT
TO KNOW THAT WHAT YOU GUYS WHO
ARE BEHIND THESE THAT'S RIGHT
NOW. TO STAND WITH US AND NOT
AGAINST US. AND DON'T TAKE ARE
RIGHT AWAY. TO RECALL THE
GOVERNMENT WENT OUT OF CONTROL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY SENT. OKAY.
WE'LL NOW OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC TESTIMONY
MODERATED WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE TO WHICH IS JUST FINE
. IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THAT BAD MOVIE
ROLE AT THAT TIME SHE. OUR FIRST
COMMENT IS WE HAVE TO ASK YOU
JUST ONE MOMENT HERE. IN
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD THERE MAY.
WE CAN HEAR YOU. RIGHT YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. BUT YOUR AND YOUR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SHERRY ALAS
HEY GUYS DONE TODAY STE. WELL
I'M GOING TO ENJOY YOU KNOW
THAT- I WAS A VOLUNTEER FOR.
RECALL GAVIN NEWSOM. THE OTHER
THING THAT THE SECRETARY OF
STATE IS SAYING IS REALLY NOT
ACCURATE- L. AS A VOLUNTEER. I
DURING MY TIME AND MY MONEY. ALL
KINDS OF THINGS SO THE TAXPAYERS
WOULDN'T HAVE TO DO THAT
DEFINITELY. THIS THESE RECALLS
ARE ARE FOR MENTAL RIGHT
INCLUDING GORE'S. YOUR RATES TO.
YOUR TAXPAYERS TWO CORRECT. IF
YOU CHANGE THE GAME NOW IT MIGHT
COME BACK TO HURT YOU LATER.
BECAUSE HE- IT WOULD INFRINGE
UPON DEMOCRACY. I URGE YOU GUYS
TO REALLY CONSIDER SO SOME
FACTORS HERE. ESPECIALLY WITH A
BIGGER THAT MENTIONED SOMETHING
ABOUT PAID PETITIONING. THOSE
ARE JOBS. DO YOU WANT TO TAKE
DOWN THE LANE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALSO I THOUGHT. MODERATOR
ZERO NINE TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING- THERE WERE A
COUPLE OF STATEMENTS THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO CORRECT FIRST THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA DON'T WANT
THIS. SECOND WE DO NOT LIVE IN A
DEMOCRACY NO WERE IN THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION DOES THE WORD
DEMOCRACY EXIT WE LIVE IN A
REPRESENTATIVE CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC. THIS LEGISLATION IS
DESIGNED TO ELIMINATE THE PUBLIC
FROM DISCOURSE. NOTHING SCREAMS
CORRUPTION LIKE YOUR LEGISLATORS
ATTEMPTING TO PASS LEGISLATION
THAT PREVENTS YOU FROM RECALLING
THEM. PLEASE KEEP THAT IN MIND
THIS IS AN ELECTION YEAR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU EITHER
A MINOR IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE
END ZERO AT THIS TIME. AB TWO
MORE IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THE NEXT COMMENT.
IT'LL BE JUST ONE MORE COMMENT
WE DO HAVE TO IN Q. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WHY TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT. IF OUR ELECTIONS
WORKED GREAT THERE WOULD BE NO
NEED FOR A RECALL DISCUSSION.
WHAT YOU FOLKS NEED TO FOCUS ON
IS AND- INTEGRITY. THANKS ARE
ALEXION LOOK AT WATER WALK. ALL
RIGHT OR WHAT IS A REFLECTION OF
THE WE THE PEOPLE. THEN LOOK AT
NEW SOME. WHAT BALL GAME THIS
WEEKEND. I TOLD HIM FOR CREEK.
AND WE THE PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO
OUR RECALL PROCESS CHANGE
BECAUSE THAT'S ALL WE HAVE LEFT
IN STOCK THIS CORRUPTION IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MODERATORS THAT ONE
PERSON. YEP ONE MORE LIGHT
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE HI
YES- WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO HAVE
RECALL ELECTIONS AND I DON'T-
SUPPORT MAKING AMENDMENTS TO
THAT SAM ADAMS SAID GOVERNOR
HAVE. NO RIGHT TO SPEECH AND
TAKE WHAT THEY PLEASE GEORGE
MASON SAID NEVER LOSE SIGHT OF
THIS FUNDAMENTAL MAXIM THAT ALL
POWER WITH ORIGINALLY LODGED IN
CONSEQUENTLY IS DERIVED FROM THE
PEOPLE. WE HAVE NOT GIVEN YOU
POWER TO INFRINGE ON OUR RIGHT
JOHN ADAMS SAID TRUST NO MAN
LIVING WITH POWER TO ENDANGER
THE PUBLIC LIBERTY IF EITHER
SIXTY THEIR POWER THE PEOPLE
HAVE A RIGHT TO REVOKE THEIR
CONSENT EVER PRESENTATION. SO I
URGE YOU NOT TO MAKE AMENDMENTS
AND LET'S KEEP IT THE PEOPLE
HOLD THE POWER. TO KEEP IT THAT
WAY THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT.
THANK YOU MODERATOR AND ALTHOUGH
WE HAD ALREADY PASSED THE REMOTE
. TESTIMONY OUTSIDE I'VE BEEN
INFORMED THAT THERE ARE TWO
WITNESSES OUTSIDE AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT DURING THIS
PROCESS ESPECIALLY IT BEING OUR
THIRD INFORMATIONAL HEARING THAT
WE GIVE EVERYBODY AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK SELL WITNESSES AND
REMOTE TESTIMONY WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM YOU AS WELL. YOU EACH
HAVE ONE MINUTE. HEY CAN YOU SEE
ME YES WE CAN OKAY SO YOU CAN
SEE ME- AND IS THIS RECALL
HEARING. DO I JUST START TALKING
. SO CONFUSING CAN THEY SEE ME
YES AND IT'S AN OKAY. START BY
SAYING I THINK IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING THAT- THE CHAIR THIS
NEW CHAIR BRIAN- IS CHAIRING A
COMMITTEE LAST TIME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN YOU DIDN'T EVEN
STAY FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS I DON'T
KNOW HOW THAT WARRANTS YOU
BECOMING CHAIROF THE COMMITTEE
THAT YOU KNOW IS TALKING ABOUT
STRIPPING OUR OUR BASIC RIGHT TO
HAVE RECALL ELECTIONS. THE
PERSON YOU HAVE SURELY WEBER WHO
WAS YOUR MAIN WITNESS WAS NOT
EVEN A LACK DID BY THE PEOPLE
SHE WAS APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM SO WHY IS YOUR EXPERTS.
YOU KNOW THAT WAS APPOINTED BY A
GOVERNOR THANK YOU WOULDN'T HAVE
CLEARLY BEEN FRUSTRATED WITH
WHAT. OFF DID THEY CUT ME OFF-
THAT SO FROM. HELLO MY NAME IS
JIM EMONDS- I JUST THINK IT'S
WRONG THAT YOU TAKE AWAY OUR
RIGHT TO RECALL A GOVERNOR YEAH
MY ON- IF YOU ARE JUST GOING TO.
TAKE AWAY THE RIGHT TO RECALL A
GOVERNOR WHO'S NOT DOING ITS JOB
IS NOT FOLLOWING WHAT THE PEOPLE
WANT. AND THAT THAT'S REALLY ALL
I HAVE TO SAY IT IS IDEA I'M I'M
NOT SOLO WITH THIS ITEM I THINK
THEIR MASSES AGREE WITH ME- AND
EAT YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO TAKE
AWAY THAT RIGHT- ANYWAY THAT'S
IT THANK YOU MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
WELL THIS IS CERTAINLY BEEN FUN
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
PARTICIPANTS IN TODAY'S HEARING
ARE TWO EXPERT WITNESSES MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAIR
GLAZIER. I ALSO WANT TO OPEN UP
THE FLOOR BEFORE WE ADJOURN ARE
THERE ANY REMARKS THAT ANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHICH
TO MAKE- IN OUR BRIEF CLOSING.
STATISM BENNETT- THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF. IT JERRY BRYAN. OF
THE QUESTION AT THE OPENING OF
THIS WORLD SOME PEOPLE QUESTION
THE NEED FOR REFORM OF THE
RECALL PROCESS AT ALL. AND I
CERTAINLY THINK THAT THE ANSWER
TO THAT QUESTIONIS YES THAT
WITH PAID SIGNATURE GATHERERS
OUT THERE. RECALLS HAVE BECOME
DOMINATED. BY THOSE WHO WANT TO
USE THE RECALL PROCESS FOR
NARROW. POLITICAL INTEREST
RATHER THAN FOR WHAT THEY'RE
DESIGNED FOR WHICH IS- TO REMOVE
FROM OFFICE PEOPLE THAT ENGAGE
IN EGREGIOUS- OF MISCONDUCT OR
SERIOUS ETHICAL VIOLATIONS AND
THAT ARE OUT THERE. WILL GIVE
TWO EXAMPLES OF THAT AND ONE IS
A CANDIDATE WHO KNOWS THEY CAN
ONLY WIN. IN A RECALL ELECTION
THAT STARDOCK DESIGNED TO ALLOW
A CANDIDATE WHO GETS A PERHAPS
SMALL NARROW SLICE OF THE VOTES
TO BECOME. THE GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA- THAT IS A MOTIVATION
FOR SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF PEOPLE
AND FUNDS TO FLOW IN TO RECALL
CAMPAIGNS. THE SECOND IN THAT
ONE THAT WE SEE VERY MUCH AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL ARE PEOPLE WHO AT A
LOCAL LEVEL HAVE KNOW WHAT
EVIDENCE OF- OF THE PREVIOUS
MISCONDUCT OR ETHICAL
VIOLATIONS. BUT SIMPLY DISAGREE
WITH A POLITICAL OF POSITION
TAKEN BY A LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
CITY COUNCIL MEMBERSHIP PROVIDES
OUR EXETER- AND- WHILE THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO DO THAT- OF. PAID
SIGNATURE GATHERERS ALLOW THOSE
PEOPLE TO ALSO- GATHERED THE
SIGNATURES OFTEN WEST OF
MISREPRESENTATIONS OF WHAT
THEY'RE GATHERING AND I THINK WE
WE'VE ALL SEEN PLENTY OF THOSE
EXAMPLES. SO I. WOULD OFFER THAT
I SUPPORT THE CLARITY THAT
COMES. FROM IDENTIFYING FOR
EXAMPLE THAT THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR IS GOING TO BE THE
PERSON THAT'S GOING TO BE
RECALL. THE CLARITY. THAT COMES
FROM- THIS HANG. THE LOCAL
PROCESS WE BE. A RE. OR THREE
PLACEMENT IF SOMEBODY IS
RECALLED IS THE SAME AS IF IT
AND IF SOMEBODY RESIGNS BECAUSE
THAT CLARITY DECREASES THE
INCENTIVE FOR MINORITY
CANDIDATES TO TRY TO PUSH
THROUGH A RECALL AND I THINK
THAT WITH THAT SINGLE CHANGE. WE
WILL DRAMATICALLY DECREASE- THE
INCENTIVES AND THEREFORE- THE
FREQUENCY OF INAPPROPRIATE-
RECALL EFFORTS THAT THAT WOULD
BE OUT THERE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF BORDER THANK IS A NUMBER
INSTEAD OF BY CHERYL. I JUST
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR.
TAKING THE INITIATIVE TO REVIEW
A PROCESS IN CALIFORNIA- SOME
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE WE NEED TO
REVIEW. AND EVERYBODY IS
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT WE SHOULD BE
REVIEWING PROCESSES EVERY ONCE
IN A WHILE. THERE ARE SO MANY
PROCESSES IN AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE NOT
FUNCTIONAL THAT WE SHOULD BE
REVIEWING AND THIS IS PROBABLY
ON THE SCALE OF ALL OF THEM- NOTNEARLY AT THE TOP OF THAT LIST-
BUT AS WE'VE GONE THROUGH THIS.
AND LISTEN TO THE TESTIMONY AND
THINGS. ARE THEIR IDEAS TO
CHANGE ANYTHING CAN BE CHANGED
BUT WE HAVE TO WAY OUT IS THAT
CHANGE NECESSARILY- SOMETHING
THAT IS GOOD FOR THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN THIS PROCESS OR
NOT. AND AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT I TAKE- ESPECIALLY IN THIS
CASE. VERY VERY SERIOUSLY- SO-
THANK YOU FOR ENGAGING IN THIS
AND- I APPRECIATE TO EVERY YOU
KNOW THE TIME THAT PEOPLE PUT
IN. AND SPEND HERE- BUT- I ALSO
APPRECIATE- YOU KNOW THE
COMMENTS FROM FRUSTRATED PEOPLE
OUT THERE- THAT ARE AFRAID THAT
WE ARE GOING DOWN THE WRONG
PATH. AND BACK ON THE UC
BERKELEY A GENTLEMAN ACTUALLY HE
WAS IN FAVOR OF CHANGING THE
RECALL PROCESS HE JUST OFFERED
AN OPINION ON THAT PARTICULAR
ITEM. THAT A DEFERRED WITH OTHER
PEOPLE THAT- HAVE. HAVE TALKED
ABOUT- THE SIGNATURE PROCESS.
THANKS FOR CLARIFICATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND WITH THAT
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU ALL.